hey everyone welcome to simply learn's
youtube channel in this session we will
be learning the game development
tutorial but before we begin i would
like to take a quick confirmation from
our viewers if the screen is purely
visible and the audio is clear
if yes kindly type yes in the chat
section and if there are any issues that
can be resolved from rn kindly do let us
know in the chat section
great i can see a lot of positive
responses from our viewers thank you so
i think it's a clear indication that we
can get started i would also like to
tell you guys that we have daily updates
on multiple technologies so if you're a
tech geek in a continuous hunt for
latest technological trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn now without further
ado let's get started with the agenda
for today's discussion
so we will get started with a brief
introduction to game development and
what are the trends on game development
in the current id industry salary
discussions and many more followed by
that we will learn the best games that
are suitable for game development in the
current iit industry then we will learn
the c-sharp game development tutorial
and followed by the tutorial we will try
to develop some games using c sharp that
is the unity game in c and tic tac toe
game in c for the fundamentals to be
revamped then we will get into
javascript game development tutorial
once we are done with the fundamentals
on javascript game development we will
try to create a worldly game using
javascript and then another tic-tac-toe
game but this time we will be developing
the same game using javascript and
followed by that we will get into the pi
game tutorial once we are done with the
pie game tutorial and an example game
development program using pygame we will
get into the java game development
tutorial and also we will develop some
games using the java programming
language so i hope i made myself clear
with the agenda hope this session will
be interesting and informative to you
guys so now handing over the session to
our training experts
by 2017 the worth of the gaming industry
will be
102.2 billion dollars which is equal to
sending 60 shuttles into space
the number of mobile gaming apps will be
equal to the population of 21
earth-sized planets
a top-rated game developer will earn
more than the ceos of most mid-sized
companies
some of the most successful games would
have been developed by rookies in their
living rooms
so excited to start a career in game
development enroll to our site of course
is on game development and set yourself
up for an exciting and successful career
we have a range of game development
courses from simple courses that teach
you to make a mobile game with no coding
experience to comprehensive bundles that
enable you to make cutting edge dynamic
3d games
courses cover mobile app development
game hacking 3d game development game
character animation 3d sculpting scene
lighting game dynamics and much more
learn by actually creating games as you
train with us with the video game
industry reaching new heights with every
passing year it has been an uphill
battle meeting the demand with supply
what used to be branded as a form of
entertainment which is often nonsensical
has now become a career of many
professionals across the globe thanks to
this rise in esports culture
a small category of esports will be
featured in the 2025 olympics much to
the surprise of the general public who
never saw video games to be anything
more than a leisure activity
with so much capital being invested in
this industry the development of these
games have their own career trajectory
and one of the most exciting prospective
roles in the market today
starting from coding at its base level
to complex machine learning algorithm at
its peak video game development has a
lot of potential for growth due to the
variety of languages one can learn to be
able to contribute
so hey everyone this is biaber from
simply learn and welcome to this video
on the best programming language for
gaming
before we get started let's understand
the metrics behind the rise in esports
culture
according to a business insider article
the esports industry is on track to be a
1.5 dollar industry by 2023
this growth has been accentuated by the
fact that a multitude of academic
institutions now provide scholarships to
those people looking to pursue a career
in video games and represent their
organization professionally
as you can see the infographic the
growth in advertising revenue during
esports events have been growing at a
rapid rate
from 143 million in 2018 to 26 million
in 2020
video games have found prominence in the
daily household
it is said that 3 out of every 5
americans have either a sony playstation
an xbox or a personal computer built
specifically for gaming
such a high audience invites higher
sales figures which in turn generated
industry topping revenues
we can see the rate of growth getting
stabilized as we move into the 2020s
indicating an onset of esports culture
normalization which will most likely see
it take one of the top revenue
generating streams in the recreational
sector
it's not just about the people though
thanks to this new era of digital sales
and easy access to gaming consoles
reputed game developers like electronic
arts ubisofts and bethesda have
constantly managed to rack up higher
production budgets
in some of these game titles
the production cost is more than in some
hollywood movies
starting from hiring voice actors and
animators to finding programmers and
investing in marketing this kind of
splurge of cash has been made possible
purely due to the consistent return of
investment in games like gta 5 and
destiny
not every ambitious project will get
enough praise in the industry but
companies pay good money to make sure
they hit the right formula as often as
they can thus increasing the necessity
of efficient game developers
with the right foundation and
programming one can take the first step
to become a sought after name in the
video gaming industry
thankfully this video is here to give
you a primer on the right programming
language to choose for your career
let's have a look at what we are going
to learn today
we first learn what is video game
development then move on to the top
programming languages in the market to
start coding games on
we also look at some of the honorable
mentions when it comes to languages that
just miss the cut then have a
demonstration on how we can create a
game using python
so let's understand about what game
development is
video game development is the art of
creating a game writes from its design
development all the way to its release
it has various aspects throughout the
development cycle
artifact design good user experience
balanced game mechanics realistic
animations and voice acting a reliable
network profile among many other things
the highlights include the process of
designing the look and behavior of games
all the menus to all the maps that are
included in the game need to be designed
by certain animators and graphic
designers that work together as a team
in certain sects of the game
we also have reliable artifact designing
to the voice models which help in giving
life to the game
while programming is not exactly
compulsory to learn game development it
is essential in certain segments for
example while designing the look and
behavior of the games or the sound
designs programming is not as important
however when depending on the behavioral
aspect of some game engines programming
is a must
while many of these departments don't
need programming things like mechanics
input configuration and networking setup
can all be programmed from a single guy
to teams dispersed all around the globe
depending on the scope of the project
to help reduce the load for certain
developers game engines have been
created
they act as a set of pre-configured
modules and mechanics to accelerate the
process of game development
engines also help an easy distribution
among different platforms thereby
reducing the workload of the development
team by a considerable amount
engines like unity cryengine and unreal
engine have revolutionized the way games
are developed today and engines like
these keep pushing the boundaries of
what we can expect over a single
framework
there isn't just a single department
that manages the complete cycle of the
game development it is the joint effort
so let's see some of these individual
teams
the input management team has a lot of
responsibility in creating a responsive
environment for the user to play in
this team programs the kind of input
parameters to be used all the way to the
game reacts to movements actions and
interactions
the animation and design team is
supposed to be responsible for the first
impression that people have when they
see their game for the first time
b due to terrific graphics in the
trailers or an immersive gameplay
experience thanks to an open world the
design team holds a lot of weight in
deciding which way the game should
proceed
the sound production team handles all
the voice acting and the game response
in order to generate the best auditory
output
some video game titles have managed to
capture the atmosphere in war much more
accurately than some hollywood movies
apart from in-game production a solid
voice acting lineup helps build
credibility into the story and the
inverse of it leaves a sour taste in the
mouth
that is irrespective of the great
graphics of the responsive gameplay
behavioral optimization teams handle the
response of the games to user decisions
it can be simple condition based
programming or complex machine learning
algorithms that learn the user's habits
throughout the playing process to
deliver a much more personalized and
authentic gaming experience
now that we understand the basics of
programming in game development let's
see which languages are the most
preferred when starting out with game
development
the languages we are going to cover in
this video are c sharp
c plus plus
java
javascript
and lua
c sharp is one of the most widely used
languages in the video game industry
thanks to its unique xna framework
xna framework is a set of tools and
runtime environments developed by
microsoft
thanks to this framework c-sharp is very
popular when it comes to developing
games for windows operating systems and
xbox consoles
the famous unity engine was written
using c sharp to encourage new people in
taking a video game development as a
career instead of running through heaps
of codes as an amateur
c-sharp is used along with other
languages such as c plus plus and java
to create a fully functional game
platform ready for release
some of the most famous titles to be
written in c hash are the popular
multiplayer game rust and the classic
stardew valley
speaking of c plus plus it is still the
most basic language needed for game
development even after decades of its
arrival
it's very fast and compilation is
surprisingly quick even for large
products with multiple modules being
side loaded
since c plus plus has been in the
industry for so long it has found its
way into almost every platform that can
run games and is easy to run across
different systems
the modular nature of c plus also helps
in better management of memory and cpu
resources thereby improving the overall
performance and user experience of the
game
it was a major part of the development
of game engines like unreal engine and
frostbite engine which are still being
used extensively in today's industry as
flagship development platforms
the most popular games written on c plus
plus can be attributed to the frostbite
game fifa series or the unreal engine
game hallmark those are the borderland
games series
java found its way onto the game
development scene with the introduction
of the mobile phone
starting from the old motorola phones to
the thick nokia handsets java has been
prevalent since then and is a crucial
part of development
java gets compiled on a java virtual
machine or a jvm
this helps in decreasing the reliance on
a machine specification and makes it
much more scalable
java also has a multi-threading feature
that allows it to run multiple threads
of a single cpu simultaneously
this earns a significant boost in
productivity and performance
it may not be as instrumental in today's
desktop caliber games but mobile based
applications still feature java at some
level in their code base
some popular games that employ java in
their codes are runescape and the
popular multiplayer game known as
minecraft
javascript on the other hand is a much
more suited to games that run on the
browser level
since it is already used for website
development integrating gaming mechanics
into the latest web technologies is
easier
this is possible due to the vast amounts
of libraries available for javascript
and a huge support community that has
been building it since the last decade
the well-known games in this javascript
sector are angry birds and the game
known as bejeweled
lua is a relatively quick and
cross-platform scripting language used
in game development the language is very
easy to learn thanks to its easy syntax
and beginner-friendly language rules
a big bonus when it comes in developing
lua is the ability to modify game phase
many models take a lot of effort into
adding extra content to a complete game
as per the request of the community
according to a survey conducted by
gamedev.net in 2003 luger was found to
be the most popular scripting language
being used for game development
lua finds its use in the development of
popular games such as roblox and
baldur's gate
apart from these languages there are a
few honorable mentions that i feel we
should look into that got overlooked in
the above list
we have all heard about python it can be
used for both development and scripting
purposes
the main advantage of using python is
its pygame module that acts as a quick
prototyping mechanism
instead of running through a lot of
machines for testing purposes
unfortunately the scope of game
development in python has a lower
ceiling than the other languages we
discussed before
the games which are written using python
are usually simple in both design and
function while also being
two-dimensional in gameplay
these factors prevent python from being
the single use language of a highly
acclaimed game title
it is used along with other languages
like c sharp and c plus plus to create a
unified game catering to all the needs
of the player
python also finds use in training
machine learning models to be used in
video game development to create a much
more personalized gaming experience as
compared to the general development
paradigms
apart from python kotlin has become a
new language to go for as a replacement
for java based platforms
it is mostly used for developing android
games
thanks to this google's very own android
studio allows using kotlin to develop
android applications and games instead
of java
some of the reasons people are jumping
to kotlin is because of the coding
efficiency and much better memory
management
code length in kotlin is much smaller
than java for the same output
while many people are starting to prefer
coating over java for newer projects the
community and bug squashing support is
still far from the heights of java so it
is going to be a good while till you see
cortland take over the mobile
development scenario completely
now that we get an idea of how unique
each programming language is when it
comes to game development let's take a
look at one example where you can
understand how the games are created on
a very small scale i use python for this
demo and the application being run is
the classic snake game let's jump in
i will be using the software pie chart
which is a development environment for
python
we use this environment for coding the
game functionality as well as testing it
as a prototype
before i proceed i would like to make
you aware that python needs to be
installed on the machine before start
writing code along with pie chart or
does any other software which can
compile python code
now when we jump into the code my first
step is to import the libraries being
used while developing the game
python has a huge library of extensions
that can be imported into its programs
in order to gain certain functionality
in this case i am importing three
modules namely turtle time and random
turtle is a pre-installed python library
that enables users to create pictures
and shapes by providing them with a
virtual canvas
the on-screen pen that you use for
drawing is called the turtle and this is
what gives the library its name
in short the python turtle library helps
new programmers get a feel for what
programming with python is like in a fun
and interactive way
the time module is used to count the
number of seconds elapsed since the
epoch while the random function can be
used to generate random numbers in
python
we use a set of predetermined variables
to be used along with the program
in our first segment we create a window
screen this is done by using the turtle
module
this helps in giving a background to the
game on which we can turn up our
controls and other graphical
enhancements
in the second part we create the head of
the snake
this will be our control for the entire
game and it will change the direction on
which direction we want to go
the next part we design the food of the
game all of this can be done using the
turtle module and in some parts the
random module as well which helps to
determine where the food will be
appearing on the screen
the next part is assigning control
variables
in the assigning control variables part
we need to assign local variables and
global variables to be used when we
provide input while playing the game
all of these can be used using the
turtle module and here we can assign the
keys that are being used to assign the
controls we have given the w s a d
commands to go for the top bottom left
and right commands respectively
after the commands are set we need to
focus on the main gameplay of the portal
the main gameplay will handle the score
management the way the size of the snake
increases after eating the food and the
way the game ends when the snake hits a
barrier or a body itself
all this can be done in the final part
which leads to the final output of the
game
let's take a look at the result
as you can see we have initiated a
proper full working python game using a
single page of code
this can be controlled using the wsd key
as we mentioned which are customizable
and can be done in any format possible
it has other backgrounds it has colors
which can be changed and we also have a
high score mechanism that gets updated
if we lose or continue playing
apart from the visuals we have also have
sound libraries imported into the game
to make it more lifelike albeit in a
snake game that makes a less of an
addition
so this is how we can use python to get
started on generic game development
using just turtle and a few other
modular functions
so in this c-sharp game programming
tutorial will make an endless t-rex
runner game so to begin let us define
the t-rex endless runner class game
the google chrome dinosaur game also
known as the chrome dyno is a browser
game developed by google and integrated
into the google chrome web browser the
player must guide a pixelated t-rex
across a side-scrolling landscape to one
higher score avoiding obstacles the game
was created back in the year 2014 by
chrome user interface designers and it
is intended to be accessed by pressing
the space bar
while google chrome is closed or
internet connectivity is lost
let's create a t-rex endless game runner
in a windows application
here's the preview so we have our t-rex
that has the animated running we jump
over the obstacles by pressing space
button and get the score accordingly
after that we can press t to continue or
restart the game so let's get started
with t-rex endless running game code
the system line indicates that you
utilize the system library in your
project this provides useful classes and
functions such as console class and
rightland function or method then a
generic collection is strongly typed it
can only hold one type of object to
eliminate runtime mismatches and improve
performance by avoiding boxing and
unboxing following that is the system
the component model includes classes and
implementing components and controls
runtime and design time behavior the
following system data enables an object
to implement a data adapter and
represent a set of methods and mapping
action related properties used to fill
and update a useful data set and update
a data source the system.drawing
namespace contains the classes that
comprise microsoft next generation
graphics architecture that is gdi plus
as a result we have a system.classes and
an interface are provided by support
link queries the following is a system
the class describes as some classes
represent ascii and unicode character
encodings abstract base classes for
converting blocks of characters to and
from blocks of bytes and a helper class
that manipulates and formats string
objects without creating intermediate
instances of string
then there's a system.threading the task
provides types that makes writing
concurrent and asynchronous code easier
finally we have a system.windows windows
forms as graphical user interface class
library framework for the internet
its primary goal is to provide a simple
interface for developing desktop tablet
and pc applications it is also known as
when forms
then we have the namespace t-rex runner
followed by the form name trx1
first we have a false variable which has
a data boolean and is used to determine
whether or not the player is jumping
this is a boolean expression called jump
this boolean will be used to determine
whether or not the t-rex has entered the
game we can only toggle between true and
false next we have a jumping speed of 10
this integer is known as jumping speed
this will have a value of 10 the t-rex
runner will jump 10 pixels from the
current location and use the jump speed
as gravity to pull the player down
following that we have the frc variable
equal to 12 this integer frc will be
used to determine how quickly the trx
jumps up and how high he can go before
collapsing next there will be an integer
variable called this call the score of
this game which will describe the score
of the game which is set to 0 by default
after that we set int object speed to 10
this is the default speed for the
obstacles the obstacles will be animated
using this integer this will draw the
obstacles to the left of the screen
closer to the player the random variable
comes next we made a new class at random
this random number generator is also
known as random which is used to
calculate the random location of the
obstacles spun once in the game begins
and when they reach far to the left of
the screen
following that we have
the pos variable or the position
variable which defines the t-rex's
position
finally we have the game over the true
boolean variable which is by default set
to false and indicates whether or not
the game is over
following that we have the t-rex one
function
which includes the initialize component
function in visual studio.net c sharp or
vb.net the initialize component method
is a method that is automatically
created and managed by the windows forms
designer and defines everything you see
on the form
everything you do on the form in
vs.net where designers generates the
code
next we have the main function of the
form called the reset function this
means
instructing the reset function to
execute when the game begins which will
define in greater detail later
next we have a trx game event linked to
the game timer first we connected the
jumping speed integer to the player
picture boxes at the top of the screen
and then we displayed the score on the
score text label after that if the jump
is true and the force is less than zero
the jump is changed to false another
condition states that if the jump is
true the jumping speed should be -12 and
the forces frc should be reduced by one
otherwise the jumping speed should be
12.
then we have the forage loop which is
for the obstacle which we have two in
this condition as if it is a picture box
and it has an obstacle tag we need to
move the obstacles to the left another
condition is that if the obstacles have
vanished from the screen we respawn them
from the far right in this case we
calculate the form width and the random
number between 200 and 500 then add one
to the score after that if the t-rex
collides with the obstacles we stop the
timer change the trx image to the dead
one and display a message that says
press t to restart on the score text
label and now that we know the game is
over and we change from false to true
if the score of the game is greater than
5 we will increase the obstacle speed
from 12 to 15 to make it little more
interesting
a following key is down event
in this function we check if the space
key is pressed and if the jump equals to
false we set the jump back to false
it may appear simple but we are
triggering the jump function which will
be used later in the timer event and the
next function in the key is the up
function first we check if the t key is
pressed and released and then we run the
game reset function we also check if the
jump is true and then we change the jump
back to false finally
we have the reset function overall this
function will reset every variable
player and obstacle in the game this
function will be executed when the game
first loads and then when the player
presses the t button
let's take a look at how to do it first
set the variable that is frc variable to
12 and then set the jumping speed to 0
after that change the jump to false the
gamer score to 0 the obstacle speed to
10 and score text to show the gamer
score next set the t-rex image to
running the game over variable gain to
false and the t-rex stop to 367.
again we have a loop for each of our two
obstacles represented by a counter
variable t in this for each loop we have
a same condition as t which is that if
the obstacle is a picture box with the
tag of the obstacle and we generate a
random number in the position integer
between 500 and 800 we change the
obstacle's left position to a random
location at the start of the game now
let's quickly execute this program and
see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and you can see
the game now press space bar
okay let's press t
now you have to hold the spacebar and
make the jump
so again let's press t
press space bar and hold it
so this is how the game is played let's
talk about our game
since no matter how huge the globe in a
video game is it always has an end
however some games attempt to imitate an
unlimited world these games are
classified as endless runners
this 3d runner scheme is basically an
iteration of that in a typical endless
runner a game
where the player moves forward
constantly while earning points and
avoiding obstacles
the basic goal is to finish the level
without falling into or clashing with
the obstacles
still the level frequently repeats
itself indefinitely
gradually increasing the difficulty
until the player collides with an
obstacle
an example for an obstacle as you can
see in the picture is that black bar
that yellow obstacle and the purple
obstacle
now essentially to create a game like
that we will start with creating a
platform and some obstacles
then we will be writing a script to
activate those obstacles randomly
after that we will write a script to
infinitely generate that ground to
create an illusion of an endless
platform
we will also program game mechanics and
ui like score calculation score display
etc
then we will create a player object
finally we will write up a script to
control the player object
so without any further ado let's get
started and launch our unity software
let's start by creating a new project
this will be a 3d project
we'll name it
3d
runner
for the location we will choose 3d
runner as
a game location
then we will hit create project
let's wait until it initializes the game
let's start by creating some folders
so we will go here folder we'll name it
prefab
then
we will have
script
we will also be using
folder name material
and i guess that's it
if you'll need more then we will create
more
we can start by building a tile platform
that will be saved in a prefab
so we'll make a game object here
so we'll create empty
so you'll name it
a tile
prefab
we'll be saving the game object in the
prefab it later
now we will
select this and create a cube inside
this
let's name this cube as platform
let's set the
reset the position for it
and let's scale it
to 8
maybe around 0.4
and then there should be around
30.
on the second let's make it 20 so it
should be neat and clean when we can
work around it
now
i'll be having
six obstacles modification
but
you can make as many as you need
so we will have to first make six game
object inside the tile preview
object
so we will select this
and we will create
empty
we will name it
obstacle
let's copy it
so that we can increase the process
then again create empty
copy paste and change the number two
let's screen
one more
now that we have made six obstacles
let's take one by one and create
something on them
so we will create a new cube
inside this
now we will scale this cube
as
same width as the platform
and reduce its height
so let's
take the same dimensions
this is it
this was around 0.4 so let's take
something different 0.5
so it should be a little bit
bigger than the
platform and for the third let's take
three
now this looks a little confusing
so
first
let's
bring this little bit up
and go to our material
and
let's create a material
material
let's give it a black color
so
black
matte
then
let's select color
this is black
and
drop it
so
and this is our first obstacle
let's
name them as well so that we don't
mistake them for something else so
oh
dash
cube1
obstacle
1 q1
now since our work with this obstacle is
done so we will just hide it
and we will go to the
obstacle too so that
we don't confuse items with different
titles
now for
this
obstacle we will need a couple of cubes
for the obstacle too
we will be leaving one free spot at the
bottom so that player is used to crouch
to avoid this obstacle
so we will
insert a cube
let's get its height as
one
then
five
eight
then
the right is two
now this way it should be easy to for us
to understand
there's still some gap
now there is not
but let's just do
it
okay
then
we'll take this
and
now we will create the same duplicate of
this one
and put it
just adjusting to it
okay
now we will create a cube that will
cover this side
so
we can just duplicate another one
and we'll change its dimensions
so
this one will have dimensions like
6
then y will be a little shorter so that
we have a space in the bottom
and
it looks fine
right now
at least for the normal eye let's add a
color so we can understand differentiate
between the
others
so
let's create another material
let's give it a yellow color
and
a little yellow
now it's little different from the
bottom
i can see the difference a little bit
yeah
now
settle up
okay
um
okay
this looks fine
let's see it from all the angles from
top from bottom
there's an ample space for a ball to go
off if there would not then we will just
increase its size little bit
let's name them as well
so these were
obstacle to part so obstacle to cube
one
then we will have these s
two
and we'll name this one as we three
now
let's remove this one
for the obstacle 3 now
now for this one we will have
we will basically have a copy of this
but there will be a hole in the middle
so the player will have an option to
either crouch or jump over it
so we will add
some cubes
cube
this
here's the cube
we will give it the dimensions of
the previous one so one
then this will get eight
this will get two
then here
yep it's all fine
we will make a copy of this obstacle
so we will duplicate it
and basically
down the other end of this
okay
now
let's have another cube
let's have a copy of this one
for the downside and we will give this
one
the scaling as
one
to decrease it and we will give
one
thing a little bit
let's see what we have given for this
one
i think we can't compare this let's
increase it a little bit
now it looks a little
tighter and
the airspace is
okay
now this one works
for this we have one high appropriate
height all right
let's give it a color as well
so we will be creating a new material
this one we will name it as
purple
matte
and let's give this some colors
pulper
this one right now works
and now
this obstacle is also complete
let's give them name as well
so this is obstacle 3
so it will be given an obstacle 3 name
then we will have this one
we will give it obstacle 3 cube 2
this nomenclature is important in a
sense if we have to
do some kind of debugging or
rectifying some error so we know which
cube
which cube is represent which obstacle
now for the obstacle 4
we will have a little bit
of
every obstacles so basically obstacle 4
5 6 will be the combos made from the
obstacle one and obstacle two
so let's say for obstacle four we have
a duplicate of this
and we will add it to obstacle four
we can have another duplicate and we can
have
same in this one as well
so now let's hide this one for now and
for this one
let's name this one as obstacle 4.
and cube 1 and we will delete this part
now
for the combo
let's take obstacle 2 first
so we will basically select each of them
we will duplicate them
and we will
pull all the duplicates and put it with
them
cube two
cube three
and for this one we have q4
and that's how we have obstacle now how
will this work so we will first select
this obstacle
and we will basically take this one here
around here
and then we will take the rest of the
cubes we will select all three of them
together
and drag it here
so basically now this is a combo of
these two
so basically first black will come then
yellow will come
similarly
let's close this obstacle
for obstacle 5 we'll bring back this
she'll rename this one as well and give
it obstacle 5
q1
and
we will have all of the obstacle 3 part
we will duplicate it
we'll put it in obstacle 5.
two
q3
q4
q5
now we will separate these as well
so we will send black one to here
further it
and we will just select all four
different five of them and put it
let's not put it at the end so that the
next one which will come will have some
space between them
now we will close this one
and for this one this will be a bigger
one
so we will
basically have these these these
we will duplicate
we'll put it inside this
then close this one then we will take
obstacle 3 these these these
and we will
copy it
like duplicate it
and we will put it inside obstacle 6
let's change the name
so obstacle 5 obstacle this will be
obstacle 6.
q1
obstacle 6
cube 2.
obstacle six
cube three
cycle six
cube four
obstacle six
cube five
obstacle six
cube 6
and obstacle
6 cube 7.
now we will take this one we will put it
here
and we will take this one
and we will put it slightly here
and here
the whole cube
now let's have all the obstacles
enabled
and that's how you make obstacles
now what we will do is we will basically
select each and every obstacle one by
one
and we will change its stack to finish
this is very important because
this will basically
dictate
if
these obstacles are finished otherwise
the player will when will go right
through them
so
basically they need to be finished
now
three
select all of them at once
and then finish it
we'll do the same with the obstacle four
we will select all of them together
and we will put a finish
5
select all of them as together
finish them
then obstacle 6
we will take all of them together
and tag them as finished
we can also select all of them together
and then we can tag them as finishers
uh this is basically
important because to detect the
collision between them between the
player
and the obstacles
if
it will not detect a collision then it
will never finish
the game
now we will need a few scripts to manage
object pooling and obstacle
activation to create the infinite
platform
so we'll go to our scripts
and we will create
a c sharp script and we'll name it
simp
underscore
platform
now let's go and check the code
here is the code
for object pooling and obstacle
activation
now
here we will start with creating two
game object transform points start and
end
these will signify where the platform is
starting and ending
here is an obstacle array
to contain all the obstacle in the later
on
so this game object array will have all
the obstacles stored
now let's go to our first function which
is at random obstacle
basically this will be the function
which will activate all the obstacles
we'll first call deactivate all
obstacles so that
from the start we don't start with an
obstacle right in front of us so that we
get a little bit of chance to start
getting warm up
then in the next line we have a random
generator so basically this is creating
a brand object and basically this random
number is generated
randomly between the length of the
object since we have six obstacles so it
will basically give random number will
get a random number between zero to five
because
obstacle array length will be from 0 to
5
it will start from 0 to 5 let's say it
select a 4 so basically obstacle random
number 4 will get activated and that of
that platform will come
this deactivate all obstacles function
will be responsible
for deactivating all the obstacles for
the first 3-4 seconds so that
the player can get warm up and play the
game
and have a fun
now
let's go back and make another script to
generate infinite platform
now let's create another script
we'll name this one
as simp
underscore
ground
chain
now let's go and check the code for the
simple ground
generator
here we will start by creating a mean
camera
variable for the camera
another start point this will be where
we will mark the location where ground
types will begin
then we will call tile prefab from the
platform
from the other script
we have a moving speed
12 which will be the moving speed for
the
for our uh platform
then
the types to respawn which will be
basically
before the platform ends how many times
it should pre-spawn it will be 15
which is basically equal to the one and
a half platform
then
how many times at the beginning should
not have obstacles this is the part
where i was saying we will have
we should have a little bit time to warm
up
then we will create a list
for the
platform for the spawn tiles
we will give next style to activate
variable as -1
at the start we will have the game over
as false and game started as fall
basically our game is neither over and
neither started it
and the score will be started at zero
now we are creating here a constructor
for the simple call
ground gen
script we will go into a start function
this will be the first frame of date
which will happen so basically when we
press play the first thing what will
happen will be from this entire function
so we will have a spawn position that
will be the start position so where will
be that
start pointer will be at
then we will have types with no obstacle
temporary
a temporary variable which will have
the value of tiles without obstruct
obstacles which we have like five
then we will run a for loop
till the tiles to pre-spawn so basically
it will be run for 15 seconds
uh 15 times
then we will have our spawn position
keep decreasing according to tile free
prefab start location so basically tile
prefab will have its own start point
and
the camera will have its own start point
then here we are basically saying
till
this time with no obstacle temp which
will have a value of 5
goes to 0 less than 0
it should deactivate all obstacles
or else
let's say when it goes below zero
then
it will activate the random obstacles
then the spawn position will spawn
spawn tile at the end position
and then the endless group will keep go
on
keep on going on and it will be randomly
activating a different obstacle each
time
then we will go to our update function
basically this will all happen only once
then this update function will work
this will work
once per frame so basically once this
whole function work
then it will again reiterate this
function
as long as all the conditions are
satisfied
so let's take our first one
it's saying if
the game is not over
and it started
then we will move the object upward in
the word space by x unit per second
basically we will be increasing the
speed of highest score we get
so
longer we run
the more our score will be
then we have our camera which will be
running as fast as the platform is
running
so basically it will create an illusion
that the platform is still there only
the player is moving but instead it will
be the camera and the platform which
will be moving and the player will be on
the same spot
then we have game over
now game is over
or the game is not starter
it's an over function so basically there
is two position either the game is over
or the game is not started yet
so basically we are at the post state
so in this if get key down keycode space
it's an input statement so basically it
is saying that when we will press space
the game will start
so now
when we will press space what would
happen
let's say it's a game over situation
then it will restart the game so we are
setting the scene
to active scene again so it will go back
to our start point and it will just
reload this scene
else if the game is not started yet so
that then you will game started will
will put it as true
now it comes as our gui mechanics
let's say the game is over
so
it will print the text in the red color
and the label
the label is something is like a text
box where the text will be stored so we
are giving
the this width to that label
then we will be printing your game is
over and yours you scored
and after that we will just print the
score
then in the next line we will just say
that press space to start
to restart the game
now in case the game is not started then
we will not again
give the instruction in the red
and
the label
will have the same size as this
and it will say you can press space to
start the game
then we have
gui color as green
this will show the
our score
at the
top most corner
now let's go back to our game
and run few more things
now we will attach the sim platform
script to the tile prefab object
so we will drag it and put it on tile
prefab
so now if you will click tile prefabs
we have something called obstacle here
now we will select
we will go to tile prefab and click this
button so it will lock this screen
now we will select each of them
and we will drag it to the obstacle
so now it has all the obstacles
now we need to construct two game object
for the start point and the end point
which will be placed at the start and
and
at the end of the platform
so
we will have
an empty object
as start
p
we will place it here
and
another object
this game object will be named s
and p
they're in the middle
let's tag them as finish as well
i think i made by mistake i've named it
tile prefab
let's end p
so
now the
all of them are assigned
so now we will
assign
the start point
start p
and end point
hit us np
now we will save this style prefab
object into a prefab and remove it from
the scene
so we will go to our
prefab folder
we will drag the style prefab and put it
here
and we will delete this
now we will create another game object
and we will call it a simp ground
generator
so
give it create empty
and we will name it
simple
ground
chain
and to this
i will attach
the sim concentrator script
then
i will change the main camera location
so
i will give it the position
as
10
1
-9
and the rotation
has
y as -55
now we will create a new game object
and we will call it start point
so
we'll create another game object
this time it will be known as
start
point
and we will give
and we will change its position
to zero
then minus two
then
minus 15.
now
we will select the simp ground generator
object
and
in this
we will assign
main camera to this
then
start
start point
and the tile prefab
put it here
now
let's press play and watch
now
let's play space as you can see it is
giving us still some kind of issues from
the platform so what we will do is we
will again get our platform and then do
some
changes so we will just drag it here
we will delete it here
now the what could be the problem
so usually the problem is with
either this and object it should be a
little higher
so this will be a
try and test try and test
kind of deal
now we will go here we will give it a n
then we will delete it
let's play it again
it's slightly work
just a little bit more
so we'll close this again
we'll put it here
we will take this
go and point and we will just slightly
increase this
then we will delete
this straight on back put it here back
delete from here
and then go to some ground sun and put
it back here
and let's play again
now if you look at closely it is
completely smoother than before
okay
now our platform is created
our obstacles are created and they are
randomly activated as well
now we will create our player object
this will be a simple sphere which has
the ability to either jump or crouch
so let's create
a
game object
let's call it
player
object
and
we will have
sphere inside it
let's call it
player sphere
now
i want to increase the size of this
sphere
let's increase it by 1.1 that would be
better
so it's not too small but not too bad so
that
even after crouching we have problem
let's give it a color so let's go to the
materials
let's create another material
we can have
a blue
mark
two
here
and we'll move this sphere
now let's create a script
we will name it
synth
underscore
clear
let's check this code
now here's the code
this boxed command basically says that
we will be requiring a component rigid
body for the sphere
we will give a gravity of 20 f
and
a jump height of 2f
we will give
rigid body an r variable
and
grounded as false
we will have a vector default scale and
crouch as false
so in the start operation we will be
only running it once
so
basically a rigid body is given to our
object so that it follows the laws of
gravity
then in update we will give the ability
to the player
like jump and crouch
in the first if statement we are giving
the key code w as input
so
and grounded so basically the grounded
will work as
when it jumps it should always go down
and the r velocity will calculate the
score for the time it stays in the air
and goes back down
then in the case of crouch
we will have s as a key code
to crouch
basically when we will crouch the sphere
will puncture and slide through the gap
and when we will lose that button it
will again pre deform
then we have fixed update in this
it will always be working
whether the update for its start
function that's working or it's update
function that's working so basically
we'll be
applying the gravity manually for more
tuning control
void on collision stay so basically if a
collision occur then it will basically
stop
the ball
now the floor
to calculate the jump vertical speed
basically when we will jump it will
create this calculate the score for that
period of time
and
on collision enter will basically detect
all the object for which i have tagged
them as finished
as soon as they cache that it will
finish the
game
and it will print game over
now
let's go back to our game
now if you see the player object it all
already has the rigid body because we
specified that in this
now
let's add another component to the
player object
let's add
we'll add a box collider
now we'll put the sphere in front of the
camera
directly above the start point
so let's have
two views
let's make it a little simple and add
our prefab back to our screen
now that's a game screen
so
our player object is here and we want it
here
let's reset the player object and
sphere and
have the player object
it should be here
now this works
let's see the game view yes it's there
on the first screen
now let's delete the style fab
now finally let's add a canvas
we'll
have a ui at canvas
and in this canvas
we'll have a row image
let's run it
and see if it's at the right side
yep it's at the right side
let's increase its size little bit more
now let's run it
here we have our scheme
let's place
space
as you can see we can go this this
we have a simple problem
with the placement of the
object
so player object
needs to be a little bit down
let's run it again
[Music]
as you can see our game is working
flawlessly we can do some minute changes
to rectify a little bit of bugs
from with the obstacles we need we can
decrease its size
you can let your imagination run wild
and you can create more obstacles like
this and in this session we will learn
how to make a game in c plus of tic tac
toe
so this game tic tac toe is actually a
paper pencil game for two players
in which both the players one by one
mark the cross and zeros in the spaces
in a 3 cross 3 grid
the player who succeeds in making a pair
of 3 is declared as the winner
so in this session we will learn how to
make this game in c plus
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update
so first of all
we have to make the structure of tic tac
toe game and the structure of
tic-tac-toe is like this
these are the empty spaces and we have
to mark these empty spaces with crosses
and zeros
and now these are
column numbers and row numbers which
will help us in adding alphabets to
these empty spaces
so first of all we have to create this
structure
so let's go ahead to our visual studio
code
so first of all let's name this
game dot cpp
will save it
so now let's start with hash include
iostream
now we'll write using namespace standard
now before making the structure we have
to create an array a multi-dimensional
array or we can say a two dimensional
array
so we'll write into main and inside int
main first of all we'll declare that
array and initialize some elements
all right
let's say the name of the array is space
three rows and three columns we want
okay so let's say the elements are
0 0
0 1
zero two
okay now
the second row the elements are
one zero
one one
one two
in the third row the elements are
two zero
to 1
2 2.
so these are the elements i have added
these elements because these are
collectively the rows and column numbers
of the spaces
as you can see
zero zero zero one zero two one zero one
one one two two zero two one two two so
these are those elements i have added
these are actually the positions of the
empty spaces
now
we will take
the input of the number of players
as their name
for example enter the name of first
player and enter the name of second
player so for that we have to create a
string first of all
let's say string n1
and string n2 because there are two
players
now we'll display a message that enter
the name of the first player let's say
enter the name
we missed writing e
okay enter the name
of the
first player
okay
let's add slash in
all right
now let's take the input we'll write
get line
c in comma
and one
which is the name of the string
now we'll do same for the other one
enter
the name of the
second
player
now again we'll write get line
c in comma
and two
now just in order to make it look good
we'll write
n1 that is the name of the first string
or the name of the first player
is
player 1
so
he
or she
will play first
okay
now we'll write slash n
now we'll do same for the player too
we'll simply copy this
and paste it
and now
all right
let's change this player 2 and
we'll play second
okay
now we have to make the structure of the
tic-tac-toe game
that is this kind of structure we have
to make
so let's go ahead and create this
okay
we have to create two straight lines so
we can do like this
and make sure to write slash n
in the end
now we can do same for the second line
because the two lines are pretty long
enough so we can copy and paste
it will save our time and we can do
again
now we have to create a horizontal line
as well
for that let's say
c out
and
we can create this horizontal line by
using underscore
we'll give it a shot
and
we can do it like this
so that
it matches with the upper line
all right
now
we can
write slash n
and we can do
copy these two
and we can again paste
and then this
horizontal line
we can copy basically we have to create
a structure
so
it is good if you can do it in a fast
way
or an easy way
all right but the
18 and 19 line seems to be extra so yeah
we can remove that
so that
let's make it more symmetrical
let's add some more underscores
here as well
make it like this
all right now it is looking pretty much
symmetrical
let's remove this line
yeah it is looking good now
now all we need to do is to add the
elements of the multi-dimensional array
that is space array
to these empty spaces like we have to
add element on each and every empty
space
so as you can see this is the zero zero
that is zero throw and zero column this
is zeroth row and first column this is
zeroth row and second column and
similarly all of these
so that is why we have created these
kind of elements so yeah we can also
change these elements let's create them
one
two let's make it simple
seven
eight
and 9. so yeah all we need to do is to
add these elements to these empty spaces
our main intent behind adding these
elements to these empty spaces is
whenever we click a particular element
or digit like let's say 2 or 3 then the
mark of 0 or x should be placed at that
particular position
so let's do it
and for that we have to do it like this
let's see out
and
inside c out
we'll write the name of the array
with the position of it
of a particular element
so this is the position of the first
element that is one
and after that
we'll do it like this
okay so this is the vertical line
and
then again we have to
write
the position for the second element
that is zero
1
this element is 2
and once we have
wrote this then
we can enclose it
in the bracket
all right
now
the second vertical line
and we'll do same for the third one
right space
0
2
that is the third element that is 3
now let's enclose it
in double quotes
all right
yeah
slash n
semicolon
now let's fix
it now it's fine
now we have to do the same for the
second row and the third row
so
all we need to do is to copy this
and we'll add
over here
and over here as well
instead of writing this whole code we
can simply copy paste and now all we
need to do is to just change the row
number and the column number so as you
can see this is the first this is the
second and this is the third element so
we'll do same for the other elements so
this is the fourth element
so this position is
1 0
and this position is 1 1
this position is 1
2
and this is a
second zero position
this is 2 1 position
and this is
this is position 2 2
that is the last position
so this is the thing
so we can check if it is looking good or
not
i'm pretty sure that is not fully ready
yet but yeah we can check
so we'll save it by pressing control and
s
now we'll try to run this
so as we can see enter the name of the
first player so let's say the name of
the first player is sam
and this name of second pair is
mario
and yeah so this is
our output
but it is not looking good as its
alignment is not good which i was sure
so we have to make some changes
we have to adjust a bit
this was the vertical line and this was
the second vertical line
so let's make some changes and
let's see if it is looking good or not
sam
and mario again
it is better than earlier but as you can
see this
one is not underneath this one that is
the vertical line
is not underneath the previous vertical
line and same for the sixth same for the
ninth
so we'll have to adjust this
and it's pretty easy we can do that
yeah now let's save it again
and let's hope it runs this time
enter the first name we have to enter
let's add mario first this time
same the second time
yeah it is looking good now as you can
see
it is symmetrical and
positions are also filled one two three
four five six seven eight nine these are
those elements
now all we need to do is to
make this structure as if a person that
is the player
will click a particular digit that is
one two three four five six or seven
eight nine then that mark that is
zero or cross will be added to that
particular position
and also we haven't noticed that this
mario is player 1 mario's play 2 is
wrong
that is we have we have to write n2 over
here so by mistake
we have wrote n1 and
and we can add one space over here as
well
so yeah the rest is good
now all we need to do is to create some
functions
but before that
let's make it right
yeah
now let's make this all code inside a
function so let's say
let's move this into main we'll do that
later
let's create this code inside a function
let's say the name of the function is
function1
okay
all right
so this is our function and let's create
all these variables outside the function
so that it can be
global variables
and we also take this array
we'll
copy it
and paste it over here
right
and we can remove it from here
yeah so we have declared it globally and
we'll do the same for
the variables that is row
and another variable that is column
because we know that in a
two-dimensional area there must be rows
and columns
so we'll write
column
all right so these are the global
variables
so now let's go ahead and create
function two
for that
let's say we'll write void
function
two
now inside this function
we will check for any invalid value and
will make sure that it is not there
but before that we will
create a variable digit so that we can
take the input from the user
so we'll write
and digit this is the variable
now after that
we'll write
so here we will write if the value of
token that is the variable that we will
now create is equal to x then we will
take the input from the first player and
then we'll take the input from the
second player
so
before that we have to create a variable
token
so we'll write here
this variable is of corrected type
character
token
will initialize it with cross
or x
all right
now here we will write
if
value of token
equals equals
cross
then we'll
write n1
that is the variable name
enter please enter we'll write please
enter
after that
we'll take the input
that is the variable digit
now we will do same for player 2 that is
n2
so
we can copy this
and we can paste it
all we need to change is
we can make it
0
and
make it n2 so it will display
n2 that is player 2 please enter
and then the player 2 will enter the
digit
now we have to check these digits for
each and every column and rows one by
one
and also we have to make sure that there
is not any invalid value
so for that
we'll write
if
digit value is
1
that is the number entered by the player
is one
that is the first place or the first
space
then
it would be
row
equals zero
and
column
equals zero
that is the first place
just to clarify here we are talking
about this position that is zeroth row
and zeroth column
after that we'll do it for zero throw in
first column then zero throw and second
column and similarly we'll do for all of
these positions
okay now we have to repeat this code
we have to just change this digit value
to two three four five six up to nine
because there are nine spaces
and we have to change the rows and
columns value so instead of writing it
again and again we can just copy and
paste it
we'll copy
and
i will paste
and we'll do it for
nine times three
all right now all we need to do is to
change these values
if the value of the digit is 2 that is
entered by the user for the player
then
the value will go to
0 throw
and first column
with the values three
then zero throw second column
or third column because we are starting
from zero so that is why we are talking
like this now if the value of digit is
four
then zero throw
and
then first row sorry
first row and
0th column
then
if the value of 5
then first row
and first column
if the value is six
first row
[Music]
and second column
if the value is 7
then
2nd
row
0th column that is right the value of
digit
8
will write 8
and
the value would be
row 0
row 2
and column 1.
here digit is nine
so would be two
and column would be two
after that in else we can write
if the case is invalid
we will print
invalid
all right
we can write endl after that
now this condition else means
if the value entered by the player is
any other value then the values at the
empty spaces that is from 1 to 9 then
that case would be an invalid case so
that is why here we have written invalid
now after that
we have to write an if condition
so first of all i'll write the if
condition because it's pretty long and
after that i'll explain it to you
so we'll start with if
the value of token
is
[Music]
cross
and
space array
that is row and here we'll write
column
not equal to
x
that means
that means if x is not there at a
particular position
and
similarly we'll write for
the
zero
i will write
column
i will write row
if i take particular position
there is no zero as well
so
that means
that is a unused place
so inside this we'll write
space
row
column
x
or cross
token
equals
zero
okay so we have wrote this and now i'll
explain you this part
so here we are checking if there is any
unused space which is left in the
structure to fill
so what we are doing is if the value of
token is x that means player 1 turn is
there and at a particular place there is
not x and not 0 as well so player 1's
value x would be assigned there as we
can see in line 96 after that player 2
turn is there so we have assigned the
value 0 to the token that is player 2's
value
after this we have to use
else if statement and do the same for
player 2 as well
all right
now we'll write else if
and we'll do
the same we can copy it and paste it
over here
we need to do minor changes
you have to change it to 0
and
this one would be same this means if
player 2 turn is there
then if the value is not x at a
particular place and neither it is 0 at
a particular place then that particular
place is empty or unused
so
we will assign 0 at that place
because now the turn is of player 2.
okay we can copy paste it as well
because the code is same
here would be 0
and the token would be x or cross
after this we have to write the else
block
and inside that block we have to call
the function again so that we can play
it again
so
all we need to do is we will print
there is no
empty space
all right
we can use
handle
we have to call this function
the name of the function is function2
you write function2
so now let's have a look at what we have
done
so first of all
once the player enters the digit the
value will go to the suitable if
condition
as you can see here the player will
enter the digit then the value will go
to this particular
suitable if condition
once the particular condition matches
then it goes to the below if condition
that is over here
here it is checked whether the space is
already filled or not if it is filled
then we will get the message that there
is no empty space
but if it is empty then the player can
fill the space with 0 or cross depending
on the player
so now let's go ahead and create a
function
and we'll name this function
as
function 3 which is of boolean type
all right
here we have created this function of
boolean type because we have to return
true and false only in this function we
will set the condition for players to
win and check whether the game is still
going on or it is a draw
so let's start
first of all we'll create a for loop
which i trades from
zero that is i equals 0
i less than
3
till 3 and i plus plus
now
inside the for loop we will set the
conditions for a player to win the match
so as we know that in the game of
tic-tac-toe if the pair of three matches
whether it is horizontal vertical or
diagonal then that particular player
wins the match
so here we will set the conditions for
horizontal and vertical pairs and after
this we will set the condition for
diagonal pairs
so let's start
so we'll write f
array space
space
i
will making
we are making
row a variable
i zero
equals equals
space
i
one
space i1
and
space
i zero again
equals to space
i
too
there's a mistake again
all right so this condition is for first
row as we can see
so in the condition we are checking if
this element that means the element at
this position is equal to this position
and the element at this position is
equal to this position
then the particular player wins
and that's what we are doing in the
condition the loop starts from zero so
first zero zero
equal to zero one that is first and the
second element then first and the third
element
so it is checking that whether these
three elements are equal so if they are
equal then it is true and otherwise it
is false
so here we have checked horizontally and
now we have to check vertically so we'll
write
or
and we'll write
space is
0i
0
i
equals
space 1i
and
space
0i again
equals to space
to
i
here we are making
rows fixed and column variable
so if these conditions are true the
player wins
so we'll return
true
so now similarly we'll do for the
diagonal elements
for diagonal elements we have to check
diagonally so we don't have to use the
for loop we'll write space
0
0
equals
space
1 1
and
space
1
1
equals space
2 2.
now here are
space
0
2
equal space
one one
and space
space
1 1
equals
space
2 0.
okay
so if these diagonal conditions also met
then
it is true that is it's a win
all right
okay so after this
so these were the conditions for winning
the game so now we have to
make the conditions to check whether the
game is still going on or is it finished
so we'll do that
so we'll write 4
and
i equal 0 i less than 3 because it is a
3 cross 3 matrix
in i plus plus
after that we'll write
for
int j or k whatsoever you want in j
equals 0 j less than
3
j
plus plus
all right
now inside this both of these for loop
we will write the condition of f
space
i
j
not equal to
the symbol that is cross
and it is also not equal to
it is i
j
[Music]
also not equal to the other symbol that
is 0
then
we will return
false so here what we are doing is in
the if condition one by one every
position is being checked we have
written if the value at the position is
not cross and is also not zero
that means the game isn't finished yet
or it is still going on because the game
is played till every position is filled
totally so if any position is not filled
that means the game is still going on
that is why we have returned false
so we have used these conditions
if the player wins the game
these were the conditions to check
whether the game is still going on now
only condition left is to check if the
game is draw
so
after this
if this condition is not met and this
condition is not met and this condition
is also not met then there is only one
possibility that the game is draw so
after this for loop the control will go
to outside the loop so we have to create
a variable
let's say tie
and make it true
so we also have to declare this variable
the data type of this variable must be
boolean
so we can
write bool
die
all right
now let's come back now after
it is time we will return
false
all right
now we have created these three
functions that is function three
function two
and function one
so now one by one we have to call each
and every function
starting from one two and three
systematically we'll do it so
write int main
all right and main inside into main
first of all we have to call these three
functions one by one so how can we do it
so we will write
while
and inside the while loop we'll write
the condition
not
function
three
here it means this loop
will keep on iterating till this
function
will return false and this function that
is function 3 will keep on returning
false until
any player that is player 1 or player 2
wins the game
so
if the game is not won by any of the
player then again these functions will
execute one by one
so this cycle will keep on repeating so
we'll write function one first of all
after that
function
two
and then function three
all right so
after this while loop
will write if condition
if
token
equals symbol
x
tie
is false
i'll explain this part
now we'll write n1
that is the name of the player 1
and after that we'll write
wins
then we'll write endl
similarly we'll do it for
the player 2
but we have to write in lsf
token equals
symbol
0
and
tie is not there that is the game is not
tie
then
player 2 wins that is n2
wins
now in the last
there is else block
so this block else block will execute if
the game is draw
so
it's
a
draw all right
we we have done a mistake over here
if the token value is x then
n2 wins
that is player 2
if the token value is 0
then n1 wins
so yes here if the value of tie is false
that is there is no tie between both the
players and the value of token is x that
means player 2 wins here the token equal
to x that is cross means that the last
turn was of player 2 and the game was
not a tie and is ended so it means the
game is won by player 2 and vice versa
for the player 1
and if both the conditions are not met
then it is a tie
so now let's try to run this
let's save it first
now let's try to run this
hope it works
there are some error
let's have a look at them
okay so we haven't used the brackets
plus there are some more errors
so let's fix them all
function two and function three
as you can see there are no brackets we
forgot to
mention the brackets
here as well
and for the strings
we have to do
like
this all right
there are some more errors
so let's do some changes
and we also forgot
to make it a character array
let's make all the elements as character
and also we have to assign tie
to something like let's say
false
we have to initialize it
and
let's see if there are some more errors
there must be some more errors let's
save and run it we forgot to save it
now we'll run it
okay
there are some more errors
we forgot
to put bracket over here and call the
function one
and let's just copy and paste
this whole enter the name thing into the
main function that's where it will look
nice and
it will minimize the errors so we can
copy this or we can cut this
and
we can paste it in the main function
all right
now
let's save this and let's try to run
all right there are some more errors i
think
single quotes we have to make it double
quotes
all right plus i think
now let's try again
this is showing the error
all right this is 112.
all right
after this we have to make some changes
in this
if and
else statements
so so let's change this so
else if statement
and
write the condition
that
if digit is
less than one
and
or
digit is
greater than
9
then this message that is invalid should
be displayed
all right now let's try to run this
save it
and run this
function one now our only error is
function1
so
function1
spelling is wrong
let's correct it save it
and now let's try to run this
okay
enter the name of the first player let's
say sam
enter the name of the second player
that's ron
here it is so
sam we forgot to
mention the space so that is why it is
coming along sam please enter
so let's say sam wants to enter at third
position
so here we can see
at third position
this is the third position and here it
is
the cross now ron please enter
we forgot to add the space so that is
why it is
looking weird but yeah
now
ron will enter let's say one
as you can see
zero is at place one
now
sam
will enter
six
as you can see
sam is going to make a pair on the other
side ron will now click on five
all right now
sam again will click on nine to make his
pair
as you can see sam has made his pair and
sam wins
so this is the game of tic-tac-toe and i
know the code is pretty long but it is
worth trying and if you want to do it in
a better way then you must practice it
for like two to three times
so this is how you can create a game of
tic-tac-toe in c plus this time we're
going to talk about our next very
interesting feature that is called
dealing with another example that is
called snake game so staying keep is one
of the very very powerful
example which i am going to share with
you which will help you to understand
like how we offer a very simplest way of
developing a mini project
okay that is something which is a snake
game let's see how the snake game is
important and how we gonna deal with
this
these are our previous examples which we
have seen which i will call a project
which we have created that is called
quiz application and now we're going to
start working with our new project
now here first of all i'm going to
create a new folder
that is called snake
again
and inside this system we need some new
folders
uh first folder i'm going to create it
inside this that is called images
and
within this snake games i'm going to
create few new files that is called
index
dot html
and
here
i'm going to create a new file name
called app
dot js
at the same time i'll be having some of
the css files if i need so i can say
app dot
css so total number of three files i
have it now let me close down all the
files whichever i have opened it earlier
so
now that looks cleaner approach
so
this is the snake game for us from where
we need to start
and we have index.html file and here i
will as you should create
our basic html syntax
and
here i would like to include
our script tag
script
src equal to
app.js
that's it and now going forward we will
start developing
our next
implementation of
snakey
now inside my body tag
i would like to have some
basic property called speed
okay and later on i'll be taking the
input from the client so we are saying
[Music]
input
type equal to
so here we can justify the speed and we
can give id
equal to
game speed
and followed by value
equal to we can give the value called 5
initial value
and
min
equal to
1 that is the minimum value
and max equal to 9 that is the maximum
and minimum value we can offer beyond
that i won't allow the users to go
and step
that means the increment value that is
one
well that is the input type and now
another input we are taking input
type equal to
button
and
value
equal to
start
and then id equal to
game start
okay so we're giving these values
after that
i can give some
bricks
so two bricks we're giving it and start
working with the div diagonal
and in this div tag i'll be using the
canvas
it is a html5 feature
we use canvas
and i just give id equal to
game
area
there is a canvas
and
after this canvas
we will
the tip tag is closed here after the div
tag i can use another tab type
div
here i can say
class equal to
i may not have any class written but i
can say
class equal to related so later on if i
want to apply any css style
i can certainly apply
and after that i can offer the images
okay so i may not have any images right
now so i just leave this image playing
right now
okay and this script src i'll load it
only
before my body tag had closed it's
always a good practice to keeping this
script tag on the bottom of the body tag
always designed for good practice
now this is almost ready for me let me
check
okay so i can see
values
now it will go maximum 9 that is how we
have given and minimum is 1
start is the button which is not doing
anything but later on we can allow some
logic inside this now we have to start
working with our main javascript tag
this is my amp.js and here onwards we
will use
some of the properties okay which i want
to initialize it so we are saying r
game
start
equal to none
initialized
second game speed
equal to
next game area
equal to
null
game area context
area
width
equal to
zero that is in integer value
game area height
game area
equal to zero again
then solve it
cell width equal to 0
play score
equal to 0 again
next snake
equal to null
next snake food
equal to null
next snake direction
equal to
null
snake speed or a second say speed size
speed size
equal to
zero
next we have our timer
equal to
so these number of properties
we've initialized
okay
now after that we will be writing a
function by saying function
name is called initialize
okay and here in initialized
we would like to use some of the
properties
first we are saying
game start equal to
document dot
get element by id
here i can give the value call
hash
game start let me put it in double
quotes
okay
start
now game speed now these are all
basically the values are there game
start game speed these all values we
have to take it
okay so we will be seeing these values
one by one so let me say the another one
that is called game speed
game speed equal to again
document dot get element by id now we
are passing
the game speed
[Music]
game speed
now
here
once again i will take another point
game area
i say game
game area
here you have to give the value called
game area
okay so these values we have taken
now we'll be talking about called game
video context
gaming a context equal to
game area
dot
get context
okay
and in this game context we will be
using what type of context using 2d
okay because i want to have
the kind of 2d so
this is how the kind of environment we
want to set
next we talk about game area width
equal to just initialize to 400
next
game area height
equal to 600
now solve
we are initializing with 20
next game area dot width
okay so game area
dot
width equal to
game area width
and then we define game area dot height
dot
equal to
game area height
so these are the values we are
initializing this
okay
now after that we have to start writing
the logic here i'm saying game start
game start
dot now we have to line uh which event
you would like to take so i will say on
click
on
click
so when i basically click
what should happen so on click equal to
function
so what do you want to write it here i'm
saying this dot
this dot disabled
equal to
true
so i'm going to disable these values
and after that we want to call
another function inside this
but which function let's do that so here
we are saying function
start game
start
okay
and here in start game
we want to define the initial score see
the initial score for the player will be
certainly zero so we say
player
score
equal to zero
after that
direction in which direction you want
the snake to move so we are saying snake
direction equal to
right
in the right direction
then speed size
the value also the variable which you
have defined so speed size equal to
because
it will be accepting the value
from the text boxes or from the drop
down so it certainly will be string type
so we have to use power send
so we're using this option called power
sent and here we are using
game speed
dot
[Music]
value
okay so we are using this value gain
speed dot value now here we would like
to calculate certain things
what those are first we are saying if
okay
what if condition
uh see this function we are writing
called start game
because there are certain things which
you need to
make it
so like that we have to define it so
function initialize
we have started
okay and then after that we have written
all click within this
so this is what the on click we had and
there onwards we have to finish this
point
and after that we've started
start game and now we'll be writing the
logic for this so here we are saying if
we're saying speed size
missing if
a speed size
greater than
9
in case if it is the values hard coded
it
then we would like to write the logic
here
and what this logic would be it says if
it is greater than 9 we say speed size
equal to nine
we basically initialize to what nine
here we say else if
speed size
is
zero
we say speed size
sorry
a speed size
equal to one
that means if it is less than zero i
will be making it a minimum to one if it
is greater than nine i'll be making it
to nine maximum
and that's it
okay so after this elsif condition
is getting closed we are seeing speed
size equal to
one
so here we just say snake
snake equal to
array so that is my array for me and
after that we are saying snake
dot push
because it needs to move ahead and here
we'll be pushing it towards
by saying
x position
0
and
then the y
and here the y value will be what
cell wait that means how far it can go
so it will go within the width of this
application
okay so that's how exactly we would like
to make it
okay so here we have a call cell width
which we have given here
after that what we have to do is
we have to define our own function
called
clear interval
and this clear interval perform any
logic whichever i would like to make it
okay so here after the snake.push value
has been given
here i will be creating one more
function here
that is known as call
create food okay so here we are saying
create
food so great food will be the function
for me now you might be thinking where
this function is but this function will
be declared soon within your application
but here first we are saying the
function called clear interval
clear interval
with the timer
[Music]
okay whatever the timer will be passing
it
and after that
this clearing treble will be saying
timer
equal to
set interval
with this we're saying create game area
create
now
here in our application whatever the
value we are giving it that we need to
basically implement
so
here we are giving this call create food
is a function we are calling after that
we are calling this clear interval
clear interval will be just like in a
typical function which is there after
that we are using this option called
create game area
so
[Music]
this will be available to me on which
the value will be taken that
okay and then we will be telling you
how you can call this function create
food and how to create it first well so
we are talking about a functionality
called create game interval so this
create game
timer is the one which we have to create
it by our own so this function which we
are passing it after the saying set
interval
this function is knotted there so we
have to basically go back and create
this function within my application
fine so
what we will do is just particular one
we will try to comment it for a time
being
okay so here we have a call what create
interval
in this create interval will be
passing any parameters which we have
passed about as a timer here and here we
are calling this call create food
so here after that we'll be calling this
function called create food so let's go
and say
function create food
and this function create food let's go
and write a logic here
and what logic we want to write it in a
create food we say snake food
is snake food equal to
and here in our curly braces we use two
direction x and y
we say in x we say
math dot
around
and inside this we say
math
dot
random
after this math.random function we have
to just take this calculation
and check the another parameter called
game area
area width
minus
cell width the one which you are passing
it and here after that we will be
performing the calculation by saying
solve it
okay so this is for our x coordinate
similarly we would like to use for my y
coordinate also
now
math.round.num
height
but
here rather than using width we'll be
using height
minus
select let me give some space
divided by cell width
okay so that's where exactly it got
closed
okay
now here
our applications is now ready by calling
the function called create4
like that we'll be going to create
another function called create game area
let me go and create all the functions
first so we are saying
function create game area
create
game
area there's another function for me
after this create game area there will
be another function i'm going to create
it
that is called control
function control
okay after that we are going to write
one more function called function
right score
there's another function available for
us control we have a call write score
there's another function which you're
going to write it down here that is
called function
right score is done now we say create
square
create
square
this is another function
and finally we'll have a call change
direction
function
change
change
direction
so that's it so these many functions we
wanted to create it
here in our system
well
we know it very well that we have taken
this call create food grade food
function is already ready now now we're
going to talk about our next function
called create gain area and in this
great game area we are defining two
location
var
x direction and y direction so we say
uh a snake
x
equal to
snake the position we are taking is
called zero and we say dot x
for the x direction
we are saying var
snake
y
equal to
snake
position we are taking once again zero
and
dot okay so two directions we have taken
x direction and y direction
now here we are starting
gain
area
context dot
fill style at the united variable it is
a property
fill style
equal to which color you want to fill
this up
so i'm saying hash white color
okay and then we are using this game in
your context again
dot fill
react fill react
now keep the position values i'm saying
0 comma 0 comma
game area
game area width
comma
game area height
so we are basically filling the values
with color we want to use it called
stock style let me take the game area
context again
dot
stock style
stroke style
equal to now we give the another color
here
by saying hash
okay and then the next option called
same gave me the context dot stroke
react
stroke
react and here we pass the values again
zero comma
zero
comma
game area width
comma
game
area
height
so we are passing those values like that
and now after this we have to write a
logic
of the directions
now see the when you talk about snake
game it move left right and center
up and down so now in this case we have
to increment the situations accordingly
so we say if
the snake direction
if the snake direction
go to
right
then we say snake
x
plus plus
now
else if
also
same
let's copy this
snake direction
left
then what should happen
here we say
snake
x
minus minus
okay so we're thinking like that let me
copy this again
now here
here we're talking about left right we
set down
so in this case we say snake
y
plus plus
and in this case
if it is up
let me say
snake
y
minus minus
so these conditions we are taking it now
now here after this else if condition we
would like to take another if condition
now here in my if condition
we are
using some more lengthy statements
what's that we say
if snake x
if snakes x
-1
or
snake x
double equal to
game
area
width which we have taken
divided by
cell weight
okay or
we are taking this condition called
snake y
snake y double equal to
minus one
okay so we're giving this call minus 1
or
snake y
stack y equal to
gain area height
to save it
or
here we will take the another condition
here
yeah we will take the another condition
here call
we'll have another function called
control
which we have
created some time back and inside this
control
it will take some parameters so what
those parameters we can pass okay we can
say
snake
x
comma
snake y
comma
third parameter will be
snake
so this could be my another function
okay
so here we are passing the conditions
just like that
okay now here
this is
available to use a parenthesis
and here
we're writing the situation for right
score
which is so far the function is only
created not
described more so we're writing the
right score the score will be written
here
and here we are saying clear interval
because the timer will be stopped
okay i'm using game start
dot
disabled
equal to
false
and after that
return
that's it
so this is the logic for we have written
to this particular example
now we can use
another if more conditions here just to
check the behavior of my code if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
well here we have finished this
game start dot disabled equal to false
and we returned
now
going forward after this return
we would like to have another condition
for the snake x so we say if snake x
if a snake x double equal to
snake food
dot x
okay snake full cortex
ampersand perfect
snake
y
double equal to
snake
food dot
y
then in this case i will say
var new head
bar
new head sorry
var new head equal to here
x
colon
snake x
y
colon snake boy
snake x and y colon
snake
y
these options we are taking it
now
after that we are using this option
called player score
plus
equal to
speed size
and then we are calling
create food method again
and here after that we're using the else
condition
and in this else condition
we are saying var
new head
equal to
snake
dot pop
okay and we are saying new head
dot x
equal to snake x
and new head
dot y equal to
snake
y
so these values are basically
associating with your heads and after
that we are saying snake
dot and shift
and shift
snake dot and shift and here we are
passing this option called new head
that's it and after that we'll be
starting with our for loop by saying for
var equal to
r i
i equal to 0
then
i is less than
snake
dot
length
and
snake dot length
and once i
plus plus
okay
later on we just use the option called
create
square
and in discrete square we are passing
snake
snake position
i
dot
x
comma
same snake
dot y
that's it
so it's getting closed here and after
that we are calling the same option
with this snake food let me copy this
again
and here rather than
using this we can say snake food dot x
and snake foot dot y
okay so now this values has been added
into my code now let me start working
with your control
control needs to take three parameters
x y and the array so we are passing this
option called
control and in this control we are
taking x
comma y
comma
array
three parameters we are taking it later
on we are using this option called for
var
i equal to
zero
i
is less than
array dot
length
and i
plus plus
and after that we'll be using this
option called if condition and here we
say
array
i
which value we are passing dot x
double equal to
x
ampersand time percent
here we say array
with a position called i
and in this we are saying dot y
and this position we are checking for
the y condition
for the y condition so it returns what
true
return
to
the condition
okay that is for if condition else
return was
false
now that's it now we are talking about
this option name called write score
this right score we have to use the game
area context
game
area context dot
font
equal to
here we'll be passing this situation
we're saying 50 pixels
50 pixels and then
sense
hyphen
service
after that we are using called game
media context again let me copy this
take it again call game variable context
dot
fill style equal to here i'll be using
another color now
so we say hash
okay
now after that we are saying once again
the game area context dot
fill
text
here we are saying
score
colon
and here we say
plus
player score whatever it is
with game area with
game area width
slash
2
minus
100
and then
again game area with
slash
so this is where exactly the right score
where the data will be actually written
okay next we'll be having this option
called create square and this great
square it takes two parameters one we're
talking about call x
second is taking y
and now here we're using this game area
context
same
dot
fill style
equal to let me give the color
after this we're using call same gary
and text
game area text dot
fill react
here we are saying x
multiplied by
cell with comma y
multiply by
cell with
comma
cell width comma
circuit
this is what
my grade score is now we are left with
only one option that is known for change
direction
it's time to figure out this last
function called change direction
which takes one parameter called e
typically we talk about for
parameters
now here we are passing this option
called workkeys
equal to e
dot
and
later on we want to say if
keys equal to
40
okay
ampersand ampersand
is sneak direction
equal to
up
okay so here we say
snake direction
equal to
down so we are changing the directions
here
okay now let me try to copy this
[Music]
and here we use elsif
[Music]
four times
okay
so here we talk this
30 40 and here we say 39
and followed by 38
followed by 27
39 38 27
and here we say up
let's change to what
left
down
right
here we say
right
up
left
so three options we have changed and
last but not least here
i will just use window dot
on key down
equal to
change directions
and
window
dot
on load
okay equal to
initialize that's how exactly we want to
use now and this function what we have
defined in initialize
okay so in this initialize
we are having this game start dot on
clicking and all so you have a call
start game now so this start game will
be calling it here
okay so in start
we will call snake we have called snake
dot push
and after that we are calling
this function call what
create food
clear interval and here we say
timer equal to
here set clear interval and here
change
game area
slash speed
size
let's say you want to use it
okay everyone so our code is almost
ready so we have this complete
javascript code ready with me
now it's time to basically use within my
html
just to check how it may behave
so in my html page i have written this
normal speed
number
gamespeed value
button start we will call game start
after that we have a call canvas where
we can id equal to call game area
dev classic to relative
and
that's it and here we have a call script
sr is equal to app.js
so that's it what we have written now
finally we would like to see how it may
look if i try to use in my browser let
me try to refresh
okay
i really do not see any changes in my
code
okay
despite i'm having this because
the css content is actually missing
okay because they're only my code really
look
better
because if there is no css
it wouldn't really make
good towards my application
okay and i also want to have certain
images but those images we will take it
a little later on let me go back and try
to bring css into this picture now
so first of all
have this
index.html file with me
and here i want to use css so inside my
head tag
we want to use
link
real
equal to
style sheet
okay hr
equal to
app
dot
css
okay now
here
in my css we want to offer certain
details
what those details i want to start
working with i will start with my body
part
body
so we want to offer
the font family
so
font family maybe a little bit later on
i can use it first i want to use margin
margin 20 pixels
auto
later text
align
center next font size
font size 150 pixels
also 150
and here we want to say background
background image
since i do not have any image so i will
just leave it as a blank
okay so just otherwise you have to say
url
and insert this url
it gives some values but i leave it as a
blank because i do not have any image i
will say background color
in this background color i can just use
white
after that height
i can just say 800 pixels
after that
background position
background position i want to use center
then background repeat
background repeat i want no repeat
then background size
okay let's see if there's a effect in my
okay i see it's now
in the middle
better
now
inputs canvas we have to basically take
that here we just talk about call input
okay in this input i say font size
font size may be optional i can
make it
but let me just say font size 100
percent
then text align
center
then padding
i want to say five pixels
and
seven pixels
okay looks better now well here after
that i can use canvas
in this canvas
i want to see the background color
i just say white
after that border radius
border radius i can say 20 pixels
then
shadow if i want to use it
so i just say box shadow
box shadow i can say 3 pixels
5 pixels
and 6 pixels
and the color is
black
let's check
awesome
so i can see here
[Music]
the
logic is there so shadow you can easily
see how it has been using
and
that's it and this div
i can say
div
dot
relative
position
absolute
top
here i'm saying using 760 pixels
left
120 pixels
that's it
so this is where exactly
i program now when i say start
okay so there may be some error here
let's say cannot set a property of call
on click
null
so this we can just check this into this
gamestop.onclick
let's check
anyways
we just try to fix that issue in a
while
but anyways we have our created css and
now going forward we'll be implementing
the rest of the logic within my code
okay everyone so we have changed some
names here because there was some value
was mismatched so we have basically
changed those values
with your properties and now when i try
to relaunch my application
by
this
index.html file
so now in my index.html file when i try
to add
so
it's just as usual same let me say start
and here you can see game start when i
go up you see like it's starting right
now
okay isn't this an amazing game right
now friends
okay that is the same game what you used
to play earlier
okay you can just change the direction
go up and you can see the score 10 is
being placed here
that's it so this is where exactly the
look and feel of your game has been
taken
and you can just increase the speed
suppose if you just put a value call
what zero
by default set
whatever value you want to take it with
a start now you can see
based on that the speed can be justified
and the example can be developed
okay you can see the start button is
disabled because right now the user is
still going on unless the user game is
finished this one is not going to work
right
so like that you can see and
automatically this will be position this
is what's called food that is how we
have used in my example
called app.js you can see we're using
this example name called food
create food so in create food of the
specific interval time this would be
automatically created and the snake will
eat and increase the size of the code
okay that's it and now the css has been
given if you want to add certain image
certainly you can add it otherwise this
is the first game which we can see how
it is running and giving you the better
example
before we move on to the programming
part let's discuss what a verdal game is
the wordle is a popular 5 letter word
guessing game that has become popular in
the last couple of months
the game was actually designed by a
software engineer as a gift for his
partner but with time the game gained
popularity and now everyone on social
media is talking about this gamer
the rules for this game are simple the
game tells you if the letters you picked
are in the word and if they are in the
right place as well if the letter is in
the right spot it shows up green and a
correct letter in the wrong spot shows
up yellow a letter that isn't present in
the word at all shows up green color so
let's go through the game once and you
guys will understand it much better
here we are in the browser you can see
we have blocks over here and a keyboard
present beneath them we have six rows
over here and each row contains five
columns for each letter of the word the
task is simple
we have only one correct word if we
write something on the first true the
system will check for all the letters if
a letter is present at the correct place
then the color of that particular letter
will change to green for example if we
write here
river and press enter key you can see
all the words or all the letters of this
word change to grey this means that
none of these letters are present in the
word
so let's try another word we'll write
here
apple
press the enter key and you can see a is
correct but present at the wrong spot
let's try some more now
we'll write here let's say
tokyo fine click on enter and you can
see o is also correct and the last word
is o now we have two letters of the we
have a and o o is present at the last
and a is present in the word so let's
think of any word which is like this
the word coming in my mind right now is
let's try mango so we'll write here
mango
click on enter and you can see mango is
the correct word for this wordle game
fine we can get any random word from the
word list we have in a javascript part
so we'll discuss about it later on so i
hope you guys got what this game is
so let's move again to the programming
part now so here we are in the html part
now the task is to create this whole
game again from scratch so here we are
in the vs code and we'll start writing
the code for the same
now we'll create the layout of this
webpage using html first so let's say
what we are doing here is we are writing
here inside the body
we are writing here h1
let's say the id is
id is h1 title fine title is the id for
this and now what we'll do is we'll
use an underline tag so we'll write
something over here we'll write here
wordle
using
javascript fine save the program and
this is our actual program
save it now open it with live server
once again
and you can see we have this heading
over here which says wordle using
javascript which is underlined as well
now let's write the code again so what
we are going to do here is we are going
to use a break tag now the next thing we
are going to do is we are going to take
a div
so this div is going to be for the board
so we are going to create the board of
this game later on in the css part we'll
keep this div empty here
now the next thing we have to do here is
we have to use another break tag and
then we have to print the answer as well
right so we'll write here br
now we'll write here h1 so inside h1 the
id is going to be let's say answer
and then inside this h1 will keep this
empty fine we are done with the html
part we'll manage the rest in the css in
the javascript parts as well so let's
move on to the css part now but before
that let's save this program and you can
see nothing is changing over here in the
browser so let's move on to the css part
now here we are in the css file what
we'll do is we'll write here
body now we'll first style the body tag
of a
whole web page so we'll write your font
family
so font family is going to be
gill sense and
then we'll write here
will sense ms empty sorry and then we'll
write here
alibrai and then we have
this over here so we'll write here
trebuchet ms
and then we have sensory value so here
we are done with this
and it's showing some error over here so
what we have to do is we have to put
this inside single inverted commas as
well
now let's zoom out the vs code and
here you can see something is wrong over
here
so the wrong thing is we have to put
this send set of inside single inverted
commas and calibri like this
so we are done with the font family next
thing we are going to do here is we are
going to write a text align at the
center
then we have background color so what we
are going to do is we are going to use
the linear gradient over here so we'll
write here
linear gradient now inside this we have
to pass the degree or the angle we can
say so we'll write here degree as 120
then we have specific colors so we'll
write here double three b
seven c e
fine so this is one of those colors then
we'll write here
fifty percent and then we have another
color so we'll write here
hash
218 edc so we'll write here 218 ed 6 and
this is a second color we'll write here
50 again
now save the program move back to the
browser and we'll see if this is working
fine so this is working fine as of now
we'll check back at it later
now the next thing we have to do here is
we have
to style the hr tag as well so we'll
write here width as
500 pixels for this hr tech save the
program move back to the browser
and you can see nothing has changed over
here
so the next thing we have to mention
over here is the title tag so we have
the ids title for our title so we'll
write a title now inside this will write
the font size font size is going to be
36 pixel for the title then we have font
weight so we'll write your font weight
as
bold then we have letter spacing so
we'll write here letter spacing as two
pixels for this
save the program move back to the
browser and you can see
we have this heading over here which
says wordle using javascript and
that's it so the next thing we are going
to do here is we are going to write the
code for board so we'll write here hash
board
and we'll write here
width of this board is going to be 350
pixels so we'll write here 350 then we
have the height as well so we'll write
here the height as 420 pixels
and then we have margin so we'll write
your margin
margin is going to be
0 and auto then we have margin top so
we'll write here margin top
okay so we have to write a margin top
and margin top is going to be three
pixels so we'll write here three pixels
then we have the display as flex
and then lastly we have the flex link so
we'll write your flex wrap as wrap
now save the program and
[Music]
here you can see some things are changed
over here now let's style other things
as so
the next thing we have to change here is
the time so tile is a class over here
we'll go back to html and you can see we
have no class named tile over here so
we'll define this class later on in the
javascript part
so we'll write here tile now inside here
what we'll do is we'll style the box
first
so we'll put a comment over here as box
then we'll write here border
border is going to be 2 pixels solid
and the rgb value of the border color is
19
then for green we have 18 and for blue
we have
80. fine
so this is the border color then we have
width so width is going to be
60 pixels and then we have height as
well so we'll write here height height
is going to be 60 pixels again
then we have margin so we'll write your
margin margin is going to be 2.5 pixels
let's say
now we'll style the text as well so
we'll
mention it over here we'll comment
text over here now we'll
define the color so the color for text
is going to be black then we have the
font size font size is going to be 36
pixels
and after font size we have the font
width so we'll write your font weight
font weight is going to be
bold
then we have display so we'll write a
display as flex
and then we have
justify content at the center and
finally we have align items
at the center
so we'll write here align items and
center
so here we are done with the styling of
the body title and board now we are left
with the keyboard the colors were
correct absent and present letters so
we'll write the code for it later on for
now let's move ahead to the javascript
part but before that let's save this
program once and we'll check
so here you can see nothing has changed
as of now so
[Music]
let's refresh it once and we'll see if
something is wrong or not so here you
can see nothing is wrong everything is
working totally fine let's go back to
the javascript part and we'll go through
the logic behind this whole game now
so here we are in the javascript part
we'll start writing the code over here
so here you can see we have the keyboard
already with us so this is going to be
our keyboard
now the next thing we are going to do
here is we are going to take a variable
as
height so the value of height is going
to be six initially so this is basically
the number of guesses we have in our
program so basically we have six number
of guesses that's why we are taking the
variable height as six
then we have the variable width so width
of each word is going to be 5 letters so
the width is going to be 5 then we have
variable as row
and the initial value of rho is going to
be 0 that's because of the current
guesses or we can say the current
attempt then we have a variable call so
we'll use
0 for this variable as
so this is the current letter for that
attempt
now we'll take another variable over
here we'll take a variable
game over and the initial value of this
variable is going to be false fine
the game over variable is for
game over if the game is over then the
value will change to true here we have
taken the height variable as 6 and the
words width is 5 letters the current row
will be 0 and the call variable is also
set to 0 the game over variable is
initially set to false that's it right
so let's move ahead and we'll create two
lists now the first one is going to be a
list of words
and the second one will be a list of
guest words so if the user enters a word
then the guest word list will be checked
if the word is present in the list or
not if the entered word is not present
in the list then the system will return
that the word is not present
so what we'll do is we'll write here
where word list so we'll write here
where word list is equals to
we are going to take a list of words so
let's say we have some words over here
we'll write here apple
and then we have
mango so
there are basically a lot of words
present inside this list may be more
than thousand two thousand or three
thousand words so for now it's just a
prototype of this
whole world game so we are going to take
four or five different types of words
that's it
the next word we have is
river
then we have height
so we'll write here height
and then we have
to queue so we'll write here tokyo let's
say
we'll take another word over here so
let's say we have title over here
and we have
ouija fine
so we have to write here hyped with a
small h
and that's it this is our word list now
we are going to create another list this
time we are going to create the guest
list which will contain all the words
that can be guessed by the user
so inside the guest list will write here
then mango
then we have
river hyped
so we are basically going to take all
these words
and we are going to paste them over here
now let's use some more words so let's
say we are
using here
carbo then we have let's say another
word over here
proxy fine so we have these words in the
guest list as well
now the next thing we have to do is the
guest list will also contain the words
from the word list right so what we'll
do here is we'll write here
yes list and guest list is going to be
guest list dot concat so what we are
doing here is we are basically
performing concatenation so we'll write
here word list inside this and
that's it
now it's time to pick up a random word
from the word list we have for that
we'll use traditional math dot random
method so for that what we'll do is
we'll write here
where
word
and we are going to take this variable
and we'll write here word list
then inside this what we are going to do
is we are going to write here math dot
floor
then we have
math dot
random so this is a method basically
meth dot random so we have to put
parentheses over here then we'll write
here asterisk word list dot
length so we'll write your word list dot
length
and finally what we are going to do is
we are going to change the word to
uppercase so that's why we are writing
here two uppercase over here so this is
also method
now that's it let's print this word and
what we'll do is we'll write a
console.log
we are going to print this word on a
console fine
so here we are done with the task of
picking up a random word from the list
of words now the next thing we have to
do is to work upon the body of this game
and then on the screen keyboard
now the next thing we have to do is to
work upon the body of this game and on
screen keyboard we have on our web page
but before that let's save this program
once
more back to the browser open console
and here you can see
again on refreshing the web page the
word is changing over here it's taking a
random word from the word list you can
see on refreshing we have river as of
now
i'm not sure if you guys are able to see
it so let me zoom it out a bit now
refresh this page and you can see the
word is changing over here we have a
list of words and a random word will be
picked at once
so here you can see
now it's working totally fine so let's
move on and now we'll write the code for
the body and the onscreen keyboard so
we'll write here window
dot on load so we'll write your window
dot on load
and on loading we are going to create a
function fine so we are going to
initialize so we are going to write here
initialize
and we are going to call this initialize
function fine now the next thing we have
to do is we have to create this function
so we'll write here
function
initialize
now what we have to do is we have to
create the game board now so
for that we are going to use the for
loop we are going to write here for
let
r is equals to 0 so the initial value of
r is going to be 0 r is
less than height so this is the
condition and we are going to
write here r plus plus fine
now inside the body of this for loop we
have to take another for loop we have to
take the for loop for column as well
so we are going to write here for let's
say we have variable c and the initial
value is
set to 0 and the condition is going to
be c less than the
width so we'll write here c less than
width
and then we'll write here c plus plus
fine
now we have to write here again this
curly braces because we are going to
write inside this for loop now so we'll
write here let
i so tile is a class
we have in a css file so we have new
style over here we'll write here
document
dot
create element so we are going to use
document.createelement over here and
then we are going to write here
span fine
now the next thing we have to write here
is the tile id so we'll write it tile
dot id is equals to r dot
tostring
fine so we have to write here r.2 string
is a method so
then we have to write here plus
now inside double inverted commas we
have to put a dash over here then we
have to write here plus and we have to
add the c
value so first we'll convert the value
of c to string and then we'll add it
away so we'll write here plus c dot to
string
so we'll write here c dot to string we
are going to call this method again and
that's it
fine the next thing we have here is tile
dot
plus list then what we'll do is we'll
write over here add and we are going to
add the tile class over here so we are
going to write it tile
and the next thing we have to do is tile
dot
inner text so we have to write here in a
text
and we have to give the value as null
over here
fine the next thing we have to do is we
have to write here document dot
get element by id then we have to get
the element of
basically we have to get the value of
board so what we are going to do is we
are going to pass your board and we are
going to pass
append child away so we will write it
append child and we are going to append
the values of board and time
so we'll write in type
fine
that's it save the program move back to
the browser and you can see we have
this board over here so you can see the
board over here we are able to
see it so we have five columns you can
see one two three four five and six rows
away fine so it is working totally fine
till now
now let's create the keyboard as well so
we have to write here after this for
loop so what we are going to do is we
are going to create a keyboard so let's
write a comment over here we will write
here keyboard
and we'll start writing the code over
here so we are going to take a
variable over here so let's say the
variable name is keyboard and now what
we have to do is we have to write the
values present inside the keyboard we
already have those values over here so
we'll copy these from here
and we are going to paste them over here
fine
so let's do one thing let's write it
this way so we have the keyboard over
here we have all the keyboard
keys of the keyboard you can see we have
qw ert by uiop then we have the next
line and finally we have the enter key
zx cvb and mn backspace fine
so this is a symbol for backspace
basically you can download it from
google as well
now the next thing we have to do is we
have to define here for loop we'll write
here for
we are going to take a keyword let i is
equals to 0
then we have i less than
keyboard dot
length and
then we have i plus plus over here fine
so now inside this for loop what we are
going to do is we are going to take a
variable so we will write here where
current row so we'll write here where
current row is equals
to
keyboard and what we are going to do is
we are going to pass here i inside this
then we have let
keyboard row
is equals
to
then we'll write your document
dot create element so we'll write your
document.createelement
and we are going to create a div tag
over here fine so we will write here div
then we'll write here keyboard
row
dot
class list dot add we are going to add
the keyboard row class over here so
we'll define this class later in the css
file keep this thing in mind
we'll write here keyboard
row so we'll write here keyboard and
then we'll write a hyphen fine so this
is going to be a class we are going to
define it later in the css part
i keep mentioning it again and again so
that you guys will remember what we have
to do later on so we'll take another for
loop over here let's say we have a
variable named as j
will write here let's j is equals to 0
j less than
current row
dot
length
and we'll pass j plus plus over here
fine
now we'll
write inside the body of this for loop
again so we'll write here let
key tile so we'll write here let ketil
is another variable we have taken over
here so we are going to
write a document dot
create element and then we'll create a
div tag over here so we'll write here
div
and then we'll write here let
key so k is another variable over here
so we'll write here current row and
we'll pass j inside it
so we'll write here key tile
dot
inner text so we'll write a key tile dot
inner text
is equals to and we are going to pass
the value of key away fine then after
this will
use the if else statement so we'll write
here if key
is equals to is equals
to enter so what will happen is
the key tile id will change to enter so
what we are going to do is we are going
to write here inside this
key tile dot id
is equals
to enter
and
we have to use the else if statement as
well for other keys so we'll write here
save
key is equals to is
equals to backspace so we have a symbol
for backspace here
so we'll copy it from here we'll paste
the symbol over here
and now inside the body of this else if
statement will write key
tile dot id
is equals to
backspace fine
so that is going to be backspace then we
have another elsif so we'll write here
else
if
we'll write here a
and we'll put less than equals to sign
and we'll write here key
will pass another condition so we'll
write here key is
less than equals to
z
and what will happen is
the key tile id
is going to be
key
plus
key
fine
and that's it we are going to add an
event listener over here to process the
key
so after this what will happen is we'll
put a semicolon over here first and
after the body of this elsevtech what we
have to do is we have to write here key
tile dot
add event listener so we have to add an
event over here we'll
write a click
command process fine so this is going to
be the event
and
now we have to write some more code over
here so we'll write it if
and we'll write here key is equals to is
equals
to enter again
then what will happen is
key
tile the key tile dot
class list so we are going to add a
class over here so we'll write here add
and we are going to name the class as
let's say
enter key
type
fine so we'll
create this class later on in the css
part again then we'll write here else
and we are going to write here
key tile
dot
class list dot add and
let's say we have the class name as
key type fine
that's it then after this we have to
write here
keyboard row
dot append child
so we have to write a keyboard row dot
append child now we are going to append
the key tile class over here so we'll
write here key tile
and after this we have to write here
document
dot
body
dot
append child and we have to write here
keyboard fine
so that's it
now we'll do this letters entering task
from the system keyboard as well that's
basically the keyboard we have in our
system so for that what we are going to
do is we are going to write here
document dot
add event listener so we are going to
add an event
then we'll write here
key up
key up is going to be the event then
we'll write here
e inside this and
we'll create an arrow function over here
so
this is going to be an anonymous arrow
function
now inside the body of this function
what we'll do is we'll write here
process
input and we are going to pass eo
fine
so
this is basically the keyboard part we
have save the program move back to the
browser and we'll see
you can see the process key is not
defined over here is the error so we'll
define the process key later
now what we'll do is we'll write the css
part for the keyboard and for that we'll
move back to the css file
so here we are in the css file and what
we'll do is we'll define the classes
over here so the first class we have is
the keyboard
row class so we'll write here dot
keyboard row
now we'll write over here width of the
keyboard which is going to be 400 pixels
then we have
margin so we'll write here margin margin
is going to be 0 and auto for this
keyboard then we have the display as
flex and finally we have the flagstaff
flex wrap is going to be wrap
and that's it for the keyboard row class
then we have the key tile class so we'll
write here key
tile
and now inside this what we are going to
do is we are going to mention the width
again width of the key tile is going to
be 36 pixel
then the height we have of this key time
so
we'll write here height height is going
to be 40 pixels let's say then we have
margin so margin is going to be
one pixel again for the key tile
then we have the border border is going
to be 1 pixel solid in
nature and the rgb value is
12 comma 12 comma 12 which is blank so
then we have the border radius border
radius is going to be 5 pixels again
and then we have to mention the font
family for the text so the font family
is going to be
this one and then we have cambria
coaching georgia times times new roman
and serif over
fine
now the next thing we have to mention
for the text is the font size
so we are going to write your font size
as 20 pixels then we have font weight
font weight is going to be bold then we
have the display display is going to be
flex
and finally we have to justify content
at the
center
fine
then we have to align these items at the
center as well
and that's it now we have to write the
code for the enter key type so we'll
write here dot
enter
key tile and inside here we have to
mention the width width is going to be
76 pixels for the enter key
you have seen that key is bigger in size
than other keys so we have to mention
the height height is going to be the
same as 40 pixels
then we have margin margin is going to
be one pixel again for this enter key
and
we have the
border as well border is going to be one
pixel
solid so we have to write your one pixel
solid and rgb value is
going to be zero comma
zero comma
so we'll
remove this blue and green from here and
that's it the rgb value is black
basically then we'll write your border
radius
model radius is again going to be 5
pixels for the enter key as now we have
to mention
for the text as well so the font size is
going to be 20 pixels
and then we have
font weight so font weight is going to
be
[Music]
bold and then we have display as flex
finally we have
justify content at the center and
we have to align items at the center is
fine
so we are done with the entire tile as
well now what we'll do next is we'll
move back to the javascript part but
before that let's save this program
and we'll move back to the browser once
again you can see it says process key is
not defined we'll define it later on
so for now let's move back to the
javascript part again
now what we have to do is we have to
create a function over here so we are
going to create the function process
input
before we move on to the process input
function what we'll do is we'll create
the process key function because we are
getting the error for this again and
again so we'll write here
function then we'll write a process key
now inside the body of this function
what we have to do is we have to write
here e is equals to
code
and then we'll write here
this dot
id
fine
so i guess it will work fine then what
we have to do is we have to write a
process input and we have to pass eoa
fine we have to call the process input
function
so save this program move back to the
browser and you can see now we have the
keyboard over here
so you can see on clicking any key over
here it says process input is not
defined so let's define it as well first
and then we'll see if the keyboard is
working totally fine or not
so
for the process input function we have
to write here
function
then we'll write here process input we
have to pass e as a parameter over here
and we'll write inside the function if
game over is true
then
return from here
fine
now we have
to write the e dot code over here so
we'll write here if
key a
is
less than equals to e dot code
and then
e dot code is
less than equals to
key z
then what will happen well right here
inside the if block will write if column
is less than width
so we'll write here let
current
type so we'll write here let current
tile is equals to
document dot
get element by id so we'll write your
get element by id and id is going to be
row dot
to string
plus
then we'll put a dash over here or we
can say a hyphen
we'll add what we'll add is we'll add
call dot tostring fine so we'll write
your call dot to string
this is again a method
so we have to write here this and we
have to write here row dot 2 string fine
so i guess this will work totally fine
now
now after this what we'll do is
we'll write here again if
so we'll write here
current tile
dot inner text
is equals 2 is equals
to nothing
and inside the body of this is if
statement will write
current time
dot
inner code
or we can say in a text over here so we
have to write here current tile dot in a
text equals to e dot
code so we have to write here 3
then we have to change the value to
column
plus is equals to 1. fine
so we have to mention the else if
statement as well so we'll write here
after this
if statement will write here else if
e dot code
is equals to is equals to backspace now
we'll delete
the letter so we'll write here backspace
and inside the body of this elsif we'll
write if
a 0 is
less than call so we'll write here 0
less than call
and
call is less than equals to width
then what will happen is call
minus is equals to
1 so basically what we are doing is we
are deleting the letter so we'll write
here this
and after this elsif what we have to do
is we have to write here
inside the else if only we'll write let
current type so we have to write here
current tile is equals
to document dot
get element by id then we'll write here
row
dot two string so we'll write here row
dot two string this is a method
then we'll write here the same thing
again
and we have to write here
call dot
two string fine so this is a method
again we are good with it and the next
thing we are going to do is we are going
to write a current tile dot inner text
is equals to null over here
fine
now the next thing we have to do is we
have to write the code for enter key as
well so we'll write here
after this we'll write here else if
e
dot code
is equals 2 is equals
to enter
and what we have to do is we have to
call the update function
fine
so this is going to be a function we are
going to create the update function
after this function so
don't worry about it now what we'll do
is we'll write here if
game is not over so we'll write here not
game over
and then
rho is equals to is equals to
height and what will happen inside the
body of this if tag we have to write
here
game over is equals to true
and we have to write here document
dot get element by id and we have to get
the id of the answer so we'll write the
answer
dot in a text
is equals to
1 so we are going to print the word fine
if the row is equals to height and the
game is not over so basically if we have
all the blocks filled we have all the
rows filled and if the last row is also
filled then what will happen is it will
print the answer in word so it will
print the word as the answer fine
so save it now move back to the browser
and we'll see
so you can see as of now this thing is
not working but we have no error over
here so let's refresh it once and you
can see there is no error still
so i guess it will work fine after we'll
do the update function as well so let's
write over here what we are going to do
is we are going to create the update
function for rest of the things we will
check the input given by the user here
only so what we'll do is we'll write
your function
update
and what we have to do is we have to
write here a variable so let's say let
guess is equals to
null for now we are going to take a
variable guess and then what we'll do is
we'll write here
document dot get element by id now what
we are going to do is we are going to
use the answer so we are going to write
here answer dot
inner text
is equals to
null for now
now what we have to do is we have to
string up the guesses into a word so
basically what we have to do is we have
to take all the letters from a
particular row and we have to pile them
up in a word so what we'll do here is
we'll write here for
let's take a variable c is equals to
zero
we'll write here c is less than
width so
let's write here c is less than width
and c plus plus
fine
now what we'll do is we'll write here
let
current tile
is equals
to document dot get element by id
and we have to write here again row dot
to string
plus
then we have to put a hyphen over here
then we have to put a plus and we'll
write here call dot
tostring fine
now the next thing we have to do here is
we have to take another variable so
we'll write here let letter
is equals to
current tile
dot
inner text
so we'll write here current tile dot in
a text
and then what we have to do is we have
to add
this value to a gas variable so we'll
write a gas plus is equals to
letter fine
so we are done with this for loop now
the next thing we have to do is we have
to update the value of guess
and we have to change the guess to lower
case now so we'll write here guess
dot
two lowercase fine so we have to write
here to lower case
this is again a method so we have to put
parenthesis over here this is case
sensitive basically
then we'll put
it on the console so we'll write a
console.log
and we'll write here guess
fine
now what we are going to do is we are
going to check if
the guess is present in the guest list
or not fine
so for that what we are going to do is
we are going to write here
so let's put some space over here well
right here if
not
guess list
dot includes
but
guess if the guest list does not include
the guess so what will happen is
we'll write here
document
dot get element by id
and we are going to write here answer so
instead of answer what will be there is
dot
in a text
is equals to
not
in the
word list or not in word list
basically over here we'll write not in
word list and that's it
fine
now what we have to do is we have to
write here return
we have to return this thing so
that's it we are done with
this guess part now the next thing we
are going to do is we are going to start
processing the guess we have so for that
what we'll do is we'll take a variable
correct the initial value of correct is
going to be 0
and let's say we have another variable
letter
count fine
so we are going to take
so basically what we are going to do is
we are going to keep a track of letter
frequency so
that's why we are doing it
now what we have to do here is we have
to write here
for we are going to use another for loop
so let's say we have a variable i with
initial value as 0
and then we have i is less than
word dot length
and we have i plus plus over here fine
so basically we are done with
the for loop let's write inside the body
of this for loop what we'll do is we'll
write letter
is equals to word
and
then we have to check the word so we'll
write here i
then will use if
let account
of
letter
and we'll write here inside the body of
this if statement
letter count
letter
plus is equals to 1
fine
now what we'll do is we'll write after
this
else
now inside the body of else what we'll
do is we'll put the let account to 1. so
we'll write here letter count
now inside this will write
letter
is equals to 1 fine
so basically what we have to do is we
have to write here
after this
console.log and we have to put the print
the
let account fine
so
till now we are done with this now what
we'll do is we'll check for the first
iteration we'll check for all the
correct ones first
so what we'll do is we'll write here
after this
for we are going to use another for loop
for this so let's say we have a variable
c
the initial value of c is set to zero
we'll check the width of c so we'll
write here c is less than width then
what will happen is
c will increase so we'll write a c plus
plus now inside the body we'll write let
current tile
is equals
to document dot get element by id now we
are going to write here the same thing
again row dot to string
we have a method as row dot two string
now we have to put a hyphen over here
then we have to put
call dot
2 string over here fine
now we have to take the letter variable
so we'll write here letter is equals to
currentile dot inner text so basically
it has the value of the current type
so we'll write here current tile dot in
a text
so
is it in the correct position now we are
going to check it fine so we'll write
here if
word so what is the word
c
is equals to is equals
to letter
then what will happen is
the current tile value so i will write
here current i dot
class list
dot
add so
basically we are going to create a class
for correct which will change the
background color of that particular key
end of that particular
box or tile fine so we'll write here
correct so we are going to create this
class in the css part
now after this what we have to do is we
have to write here let key time
key tile is equals to document
dot
get element by id so we have to write
here
key
plus
letter fine
then we have
key tile
dot
class list
dot
remove so we have
to write here the present class
and then we have to write here key tile
dot
class list dot add the correct class so
we'll write here
correct
fine so we are going to define these two
classes in the css part
now the next thing we have to do is we
have to increase the value of correct by
1 so we'll write here correct plus is
equals to 1.
fine then we have
let account and we are going to decrease
the value of let account by one so we'll
write here
minus is equals to 1. let's put some
space over here as well
so that it will look good to you guys
now we are done
with the letter count as well so what
we'll do next is
we are going to
write here after
this particular if statement so
right here we are going to write if
correct is equals to is equals to width
then what will happen is
game over will change to
2 fine
this is another condition we have now
what we have to do next is we have to
write here
so basically what we are going to do is
we are going to print the console
or we can say we are going to print the
let account on the console so we will
write here let account and site
console.log
and now what we will do is we will go
again and mark which ones are present
but in the wrong position that means the
yellow color ones right so we'll write
here after this
console.log will write for we are going
to use another for loop so we'll write
here let
c is equals to 0 again
c is less than the width so we'll write
here c less than width
then we'll increase the value of c
by 1. so we'll write here c plus plus
then we'll write here let
current tile
is equals
to document dot get element by id
so we are going to write here row dot
to string
and then we have
this hyphen over here and we'll write
here
plus
all dot
tostring fine
so we are going to take the values of
these
and then after this what we are going to
do is we are going to
set the value of letter variable
so we will write here let
letter is equals to
what's present inside the current type
so we'll write here current tile dot
in a text
and
the next thing we are going to do is we
are going to skip the letter if it has
been marked correct so for that what we
have to do is we have to use the if
statement
so we will write here if
not currentile
dot
class list
dot
contains
what it contains is the correct clause
so we'll write here correct if it
contains correct
what will happen is
we'll check if it is present in the word
we have to make sure that we don't
double count right so what we'll do is
we'll write here again inside this if
statement we'll take another if
statement and we'll write here word dot
includes
now we have to write here
letter
and
we have to mention it over here after
this we have to write here letter
count
now what we have to do is we have to
write a letter
and we have to write here greater than 0
fine
now what will happen is we'll write here
current type current tile dot
class list
dot add we have to add it to
present class so we'll write your
present fine
now what we have to do is we have to
write here
let
it
is equals to
document dot
get element by
id what we have to do is we have to
write here
key
plus
letter fine
okay so we have to write here after this
what we have to do is we have to take
another if
fine so we'll write here if
not
key tile
dot
class list
dot
contains
which class the correct class so we'll
write here correct
and we'll write here inside this
key type
dot
class list dot add what we have to add
over here is the
present class fine
now what we'll do is we'll
deduct the value of let account by 1 so
we'll write here let count and we have
to pass letter inside here and we'll
write here minus is equals to 1. fine
now what we have to do is we have to
write the code for else as well so we'll
write here else
now what we'll write inside else is
current tile dot
class list dot add which class we have
to add now is the absent class
fine so we'll write here absolute we are
going to describe this class or we are
going to define this class in the css
part later on
so for now we have to
write here absent and we have to change
the value of key tile so we'll write
here q tile is equals to
document dot
get element by id we have to write here
again
key plus
letter fine
let's put a space over here and that's
it
what we have to do is we have to change
the key tile class as well so we'll
write here
key tile dot
class list dot
add which class we have to add again is
the
absent class fine
we are almost done with the
javascript part as well what we have to
do is we have to start a new row for a
new one so we'll increase the value of
row as
row plus plus equals to 1 start a new
row and we have to change the column
value to
0 again fine
so basically we are done with it so
before we move on to the final outcome
let's do one thing let's go through the
css part once again and we'll define
these three classes the correct present
and absent class fine
save the javascript part here save it
now and let's move back over here and
what we'll do is
we'll write after this
tile class what we'll do is we'll write
over
here dot correct we are going to define
the correct class first so the correct
class the background color is going to
be
this one hash
3 fc
and the value is 0 3 1 so the green
color basically the
font color will change to white so we'll
write a color as
white and then we have border color so
border color will also change to white
fine
then we have the present class as well
so we'll write here present
and inside the present class the
background color will change and the
value of background color is hash f
5 c e 2 3 fine
so this is basically yellow color so
the color and the
background color will remain the same so
okay so we have to write here border
color not background color so we'll
write your border color
and again we are going to define the
border color here
fine so we'll write border color
so border color is going to be white in
this case as well now we have to define
the absent class as well so we'll write
here absent
for the absent class the background
color will change to
gray fine so we'll write here hash
787
c7
e fine
so this is the gray color we have the
color is going to be white
and then we have the
border color fine so the border color is
again going to be white
that's it we are done with everything
now save the program save the javascript
part and the html part once again move
back to the browser and here you can see
we have a program
so if we click on the keyboard
it's not working as of now
maybe we have some error over here
so let's check it out once again
we'll move to the javascript part
and if we can see here
key tile is fine so we have to write
here key tile like this
and let's check the other key tile as
well so everything else is fine
save the program now save the css part
and the html part as well
move back to the browser and i hope this
will work now
so you can see it's working as of now
now we have written over quart you can
see it says not in word list we have
quite over here so the word we have is
title let's write
title over here and
you can see the second line is not
working so we have to get back to
this and we have
save it now move back to the browser
okay it's working now
and you can see
so the word we have here is hyped so
let's try to write okay we have to
remove this first that's why it was not
working so we have to write here another
word let's say we have a word mango
click on enter and you can see now it's
working fine now the word we have here
is hyped so we'll write here
hyped
click enter and you can see we have all
greens over here you can see the word
count as well we have h y p e d as one
one one one one and we have all the
words here in the console
so you have seen here the program is
working totally fine
the task is done here tacto is
world's favorite game we have already
played a lot in our childhood days and
still my favorite game so i have decided
to basically offer you this tic-tac-toe
game
developed in
javascript html plus css which can
create something really really great
effects for the end users so let's go
and start developing our next game
that's called tic tac toe
so in this tech tractor i will start
working with creating a folder called
tic tac and inside this i'm going to
create a new
file name called index
dot html
now here onwards the same thing
i'll be creating this html tags
and now here onwards
we want our some classes for headers and
footer
but so we're going to create some dev
tag now
so in this div tag
i'll be creating some of the tags
in which the css class will be applied
so we are just going to create a classes
uh sorry i'm going to just use those
classes but we'll create it later on so
just go ahead and create those so we're
saying do
okay
so now this point onwards is my first
dev tag inside this i'll keep
my h1 tag
and under this h1 i will be offering
some of the headings which will be
useful to contain some necessary
information with regards to this game so
tim here we say
h1
and inside this h1 it gives the message
called class
equal to header
and here i'll give the name call
is a tic tac token
after this div class
yeah here we will start working with our
form tag
within my form tag i will start my div
after div tag i will use
label
so label for player 1
or else i can say player 1 and inside
this let's give the name call
layer
label is closed
and after this label will start working
with our input tag
input
now in this input what are the details i
need first i need call type equal to
text number one second
placeholder equal to enter name
next name equal to player 1
next we want id
equal to
player 1
and then
any class if i want to apply
anyways we're going to close this this
is my first text box
and
same thing i would like to create for my
another one
so the first dev tag we have used let me
go and create another tip tag
in this div tag i'll use the same label
copy the same
paste it here
and this is for player 2.
so we have this
two players with me and after this div
tag
i'll offer the submit button now
input typically submit
start game
now the form tag is closed here
dev tag is also closed
so
you want the div tag to be closed or
before that it's up to you now so here
we have a called div class
whichever we have taken so if you want
you can basically put it later or before
whatever
so we will basically form that with this
so form tag is there later on you can
just show some containers where the
details will be visible to me
so here after the form tag
let me try to offer but first check
whether it is really working fine
so here
yeah we have this option called enter
name internet after the stick tag tool
so
yeah so here the details we have taken
input application text and input
typically text
okay so two values we are taking now and
accordingly we will go ahead now finally
after the form tag
we would like to start with working with
the tape tag again
div
and inside this div
i since i haven't created any css
classes so those we can use it little
later on but let's have
this div
and inside this step i would like to use
one more tip tag
okay and here we want to use one more
div tag
so inside this div we will be using one
more div tag
so
in this div we can just give the value
called data id equal to zero
id equal to
zero it's just the value
we are passing it
div
data equal to zero the div tag is
getting closed
fine so
that's how we want it now
so here
the first div tag is closed like that we
can create another data id so 0 1 2
total number of three we want to create
it so i want to create 0 1 2 3 4 5 like
this
so the way we have created here
for this div
let's go and create one more div tag
id equal to
one
two
three options we have it now
okay like that i can keep on creating
the others also
two
three
four
five so zero one two three four five
total number of five we have created
one more i would like to create it down
here for six
there'll be no difference because we
haven't changed anything here
okay
so the div tag is getting closed here
okay
and
that's it
and if you want to create a some clear
mode or button that you can basically
offer it later on
but here
we can use one more dip
and here we say
dew
dip classical relative
and within this step tag i can use
any image tag if i want
so i just leave it as it is and
after this
i can create one more div tag
and inside this another tip
okay and
under this i'm gonna create
a button
okay and in this button
will be having some value
okay we can secure the volume called
replay
this button is created and now we can
create a clear board
span
and here is a clear board
that's it
okay
so here
it's just
a small game i want to develop it
better
now there's no user interface has been
used so this user interface will be
using it later on by offering them a
pure
look and feel so that you know it gives
me
more better look when your application
will start
but most importantly i need to start
working with the javascript part where
the logic will get calculated here
okay so
we want to start with the javascript so
let's get included the javascript with
my code
so
here i can see here
script tag
script
equal to
now the file i haven't created so let it
be as it is
that's it so this is my script tag and
let me try to include my
style sheet answer so
i just say
link
really cool style sheet
into the name for app dot
css though i haven't created but i'm
giving it
okay
that's it
so we have taken
this html into our
consideration now we'll be creating this
css as well as the javascript
to make this example complete
well we are ready with our html but it's
time to basically go back and spend time
on our javascript we're going to create
a new file now with the name called
app.js and inside this we will start
writing the logic with our main
application okay now the first thing is
how we're going to start now
yeah
so
first thing what we need to do is we
need to attach window
dot
add event listener
and when the window will load some logic
should happen so i'm saying load
second is the name of the function so
the name of the function perhaps does
not exist but i can give the name called
app
which i'm going to create it shortly
now here first of all let me try to
create a game board i'm saying let
game board
equal to now let me have some of the
values because it is
eight digit
so we just make it
like that
and one more
for making it nine
okay
so that's how
we're going to create it now
okay now this is all empty right now
after that we're going to create let
turn
this new variable
equal to
zero
what this is it keep tracking if x or
zero player its turn
like which player turns it to be just it
is trying to measure it i'm saying let
winner equal to
false
okay now let's go and create the player
so
create
how are you going to create a player we
say const
player equal to
what we're gonna pass
name
okay equal to
now inside this we can say name equal to
name
next we say return
name
that's it
okay after that i'm defining let
here
x equal to
player
with the empty value
and again
player
y
equal to
there is an empty value now let's try to
initialize the app
okay
initialize
now inside this initialize the app we're
going to create a new function
function
app
and inside this we're going to create a
variable likewise angle net
input field
equal to first of all
document dot
get element by id
here
we're gonna take
the
class name of this particular
text field so we are saying input
hyphen
field
okay
dot
focus
okay now after this we have to say const
add players
equal to once again
document
dot
get element by id let me just give the
name called player form
okay next we are saying
add
layer
okay dot
add event listener we want to attach the
event
on which event
submit event
and what logic
add
players
okay
after that once the players are added we
are saying
let replay
replay button equal to once again
document
sorry
document dot get element by id or rather
i will say document.queryselector
document.queryselector
replay
btl
okay
just the name we are basically taking
that
and here we say
sorry
replay button
dot
add event listener
which even i want to say
click
ok that is the first event second
reset board
reset
board
that we are basically passing that
okay
now
this is the initial case which we have
it
now beyond that i will add
this is the place what we have added and
right nut slides to add the players so
this is how we have initialized after
that let's
add
please
how to basically add the players here we
have to just define the function
add place
okay so take
event as a parameter
and say event
dot
prevent
prevent default this present default
will try to prevent
the default
uh you know
behavior which is submitting to be get
avoided and now here we say if
this
dot
player
one so we just define the property
called player one
if this dot player one dot what
value
okay
is blank
okay or
this dot
play two
sorry
this dot
player two
now i just want to find it out its value
also
value
black
then what i should do
in this case i am saying alert
you
must
enter
the
name
for
each
field
the user has to add the values and after
that
return
okay
now the next thing is like we would like
to select the players in this inside
this by saying const
layer
form
container
again
const play from controller container
equal to
document
dot
query selector
document query selector here we will
just pass
the value call
enter
icon
okay now we say cost
board main equal to
document
dot once again
query selector
code
underscore name
okay after that
clear
form container
dot
class list
dot class list dot add here we're giving
the name forward height container
all right wi-fi
and after that you just say board mail
board main
dot class list
dot
remove
height hyphen container
okay so we basically taken that
and after this what i will do i'll just
say player
x
dot
name
equal to
this dot
player 1
dot
value
ok this for player x copy this
player y
2
and after that
that's it so we have done it now
so
we'll be calling other functions one by
one but that is the first thing which
we've implemented
well so
add player function is added right now
and after this add player we have to
basically call
one more that is called which returns
the current player something return
current player
and here what i will do is we will just
write function
and here we say
current
player and in this current player what
we will do is
we will say return
turn
test variable
okay percentile
2 we're just adding it with this
0
okay if it is
then
x
turn i'm telling you
okay or else
so we're adding like the current player
who says the current tail right now well
after this adding the return current
player we're gonna add another function
that is known as call return the current
player return current player is having
this value and after that we need to say
resize the square in event browser is
resized once again if the browser is
getting resized automatically the square
size of your
tic-tac-toe should also get increased so
we just say
resize
squares
and here we're gonna say this option
equal window
dot
add
event listener
now we have a call option called resize
here
and the second parameter what we are
parsing is called on
resize
okay on resize
now let's try to add it
after this we are writing this function
called
function
on
resize that is a function link for me
the one which we are passing into the
second parameter
we are saying let
all cells
equal to
document
dot
query selector all
in this we are passing
board
underscore
cell
okay and then we're using another option
called what let
cell height
equal to
all cells
with the position
okay dot
of
set width
or
set width
after that we are saying all cells
dot
for each
here we are passing
cell
[Music]
and after that we are using set
dot
style
dot
height equal to now he'll be using this
backtick and use this
dollar sign
and say
cell
height
and that to in a pixel
so this will be taking the dynamic
values
okay that's it that's it over
now we have to just launch our build
board
now
billboard
build
board so how we gonna build our board
now for this we are saying function
billboard
and inside this billboard we will see
this option called let
reset
container equal to
document
dot once again query selected
and pass the value call dot reset
okay and after that we are saying
reset container dot
class list
dot remove
and we are passing the value call
reset hyphen
hidden
this value and after that
we may call some other type of functions
also
okay so for those functions i can say
first will be called on
resize
after that we are calling
add
self click listener
but i do not have that function with me
these functions we need to create it by
our own
okay so we will just leave those for a
time being let's go back and create
another functions now so we just want to
write another event with self click
event for play to attempt
to make move so
here we try to say
cell
click
event
for
player 2.
attempt
to
make
move
now this function need to create it so
we just say function now
we just say function
and give the name of the function
to make move now
function
make
move
it takes
give it as a parameter
and here we are saying console.log
and say
now let's go back and try to check
another condition that is called let
current cell
equal to
percent because you have to read the
value from there and here we are saying
what
event dot
current target
sorry
even dot
current target dot
first element child
okay dot
data set
dot
id
so we're reading these values
after that we use another variable
called let
sell to
add
token
now here we are typing document
dot
query selected
and here
you know using backtick
i'm using this value called
data hyphen id
okay equal to
here we are using
once again in a single quotes
dollar
current cell
okay
so this value we are taking it like that
after that we are using this situation
called if
cell to add token dot
inner html
exterminatory mark
blank
once again if cell to add
token dot inner html
equal to blank
then what next
so cell to add token
dot inner html
equal to blank then what you should do
i'm saying console
dot
log
and give the value the one which you
want
okay so
in this console.log what value we can
give it
cell to add token
we have it it is taking this value to
the current set dot inner html
console.log
and inside my console.log we can set
this
cell is
already
taken
so values are already taken for this and
now we will be
returning those values
after that we will be using else
condition
and here we use once again if
current player
okay
is x
then we'll be using this option called
cell
see we have this property option
available called send to add token so
using cell to add token
okay dot
text content
equal to
current player
okay and we say
game board
the one which you have created pass in
this game mode
this value call
current cell
and in this correct cell value will be
equal to
x
okay
else
we can say
to add token dot
text content
equal to
current player
okay and say
game board
current cell
equal to
like this
okay so here we are adding the values
like that
so it is closed after that we can just
use the function name for
is winner to check whether the user is
winner or not so we are saying
is winner
okay and
after that we are saying
turn
plus plus
after that we are seeing
change
we do not have the function name called
change board header names
okay so it's just like that we're giving
it so as usual we can leave this
function for a time being
and we'll call this little later on so
leave it as a full time name
okay so your function is now ready
so the next thing what we need to check
whether
it is tie or not okay so we are saying
function
check
if
ty
we're just checking the function
whether it is game is tied or not so
here we say
if
the condition is turn
greater than seven
meters
again
okay
well after that we are saying winner
function
is winner
now what we will check is we'll check
const
winning sequences
winning sequences
and here
sorry
here
we are having this array and having the
different conditions associated we say 0
1
2 probability we are checking it
and then i just copy it
well missing 0 1 2 and here is saying
eight
and zero three six again
zero
three
six
and once again one four seven
four
seven
and next we have a call two five eight
eight
then we are checking the value of zero
for it
eight and one more last option we will
put is called two four six
six so these conditions we are adding it
now
after this array we can say
varying sequences start
for each
and give the name call winning compose
equal to
varying almost position zero
then
that copy
and paste three times
cell two
cell three
and here we get the rather call what one
two
three vertices we're giving it and after
that
we're checking the condition
let's say
if
and here the conditions you're checking
what exactly that would be for the game
board we're saying
game board
set
one
current player
sorry
current player
ampersand time percent
i just want to copy the same line
and paste it multiple times
now here
we are checking the condition for cell 2
and cell 3
and
cell 3
and
after that
starting the position
so after that
we're starting the position call
[Music]
by cutting this condition called
consense
and then equal to
document dot
get element by or sorry document or
query selector
query selector
all and here let's select the position
dot
board
and disper
okay
then after that we will be using
cells
dot
for each
cell
and inside is what we are passing they
are saying
let
cell id equal to
cell dot
first
element child
okay dot
data set
dot
id
so this is the value which you are
basically adding it now and we're using
one more if condition
we're saying if
cell id
now we're talking about all cell id
triple equal to
cell 1
or
saline
cell 2
or
salary equal to
so three
okay and in that case we can use
cell dot
class list
add
and get the name board
just give the class name
winner so here we'll be giving the
winner and a part of that we can use the
other conditions too
okay so here it is
adding the value and now let's say
let
current layer equal to
document dot
get element by id
so you can basically define it so
current player you want so we can use
the current layer or whichever
conditions you want so here we use what
the cell winner
now
small change rather than using correct
layer we can use
the current
layer text
the new variable we are creating it
currently text document dot rather than
saying get element by id
we can say
query selector
and in this query selector will be given
the value
by saying
board
player
hyphen
the value which we're giving it here and
that
query selector
value whichever you given this let me
try to put it in a
parenthesis
like this
okay now here we just check
if current player
x
then what
then in this case we can say
current player what is the value we are
using current text dot
inner html
equal to
now we can define the value whichever
you want to
operate
we just use a condition called div
class equal to
okay so we are saying congratulations
okay and here you say
congratulations
along with
this dollar sign
and here we pass
player
dot
name
and here the tip tag is getting closed
like this
okay
so that's the message we are basically
printing it and after that
we give this value
and say this message called
winner equal to
true
and after
that if you want to apply
remove
that function we haven't written we'll
be talking about a little later on and
just say return proof
so your function is ready now
and later on we can just check the
condition if winner
if
winner
or you can say
check
if type
and
return false
that's it
now in our continuation to this example
we're gonna develop another function
which
the name is called change board header
names so let's continue by defining the
new function called function change
change
board
header names
so this change board header names will
be the new function for us and here they
would like to check whether the user is
winner or not so here we say if
not
winner
then what
then in that case you have to say let
current player text
equal to
document
dot
query selector in this we'll be getting
the details like dot
board
and here we're gonna give the name
called player
and hyphen
player hyphen turn
now later on after this particular
variable we have to just check the
condition by saying if
current player
equal to x if the position is x sorry
let me try to put in a capital letter
here
x
then we will say
current player
dot
inner html equal to
now here we have to just use the same
option called backticks because i want
to go multilines that's the benefit of
this backtick and here we say in our
inner html span
class
equal to
name
hyphen hyphen
style
process and here we want to use
the statement
now this
value
we want to write it with name attribute
so it is getting close and here we are
saying dollar
with this player
x
dot
name
and then
close the
span tag
and we say
you are
up
like this
and after that
we say div
class equal to
which is going to create a class which
later on we can apply the css style on
the top of that u hyphen r
hyphen
winner
and here we say closing the div tag
so dip tag is closed
that's it and now
after this line
what next we have this called else
condition
else
what else here we say
current player text
dot inner html
inner html equal to
after this
we're gonna write the span
class equal to here we say name
hyphen hyphen same option we're gonna
use it
so in this condition so
winner conditions so let me try to copy
the same rather than copying it again
and again
i'll just copy the whole text
expand class equal to
name hyphen iphone style
player rather than saying x you can use
file
you are up you are
winner
okay so here it's getting closed
well after this what we need to do
create another function called resupport
function
reset board
now in this function reset board we just
say console.log
a small message
resetting
resetting is added now afterwards we
will be using
the game board now the same game board
what we have used it earlier
i'll be using the same conditions
on the top
if you remember
that was a game code for me so i'll be
using the same keyboard
let me copy this
yeah
with the same condition
okay give me a go to this after that
line we will say let
sell to add token
sell to add token equal to
document
dot query selector all
here
in this i'll be using
another class called
letter
now
cell to add token
whichever we've used dot
for each
square
and within this square we would like to
use square
dot
content
equal to
black
after that
square
dot
parent element
dot
class list
dot
remove
and here we would like to say board
okay underscore underscore
cell
winner so these classes we had to create
because these changes classes were just
using this but we haven't created we'll
be using it little later on
so that was the point
now after that we are defining the turn
value
turn
equal to zero because we are resetting
it and
winner equal to
false
after that winner is equal to false we
just define another variable called
define let current player text
current player text equal to
document
dot
query selector all
yeah document query select all
so here
we're gonna use the name called board
define player hyphen hyphen turn
after that current player
current player
text
current player text dot
inner html
equal to
once again we have to use the condition
for
up
and winner point
so let me try to copy this
inner html equal to
okay and in this we have to say player x
dot name
okay just everything is same
no change at all
okay now
here after that we're gonna write one
more function called function
add
cell
click
listener that means when i will be
adding
or clicking something to my
what kind of event i would like to
listen
here
we are saying const
cells equal to
document
dot
query selected all
let's check
the condition board
board
cell
and here once again we say sell stock
for each
dot
for each
and here we say cell
dot
add
event listener
which event i want to listen
click and the second parameter will be
handler
let's call
make move
okay and this function which we have
created called add cell clicks listener
okay this i'll be calling it here
perfect
later on once it is done let's try to
add one more function called function
remove
cell
click
listener
remove cell
click listener
now here we say
let
all
cells
equal to
document dot
query selector all
let's pass
board
cell
and now we say
all cells
dot
for each
cell
and here we say send dot
remove
event listener
which event
click
and second parameter will be
make
that's it so friends now here
most of our javascript code is written
now
so going forward we would like to use
css
and finally we'll be applying everything
into our html file
well after the javascript file is ready
towards my application now it's time to
go and create
our html file now sorry the css
so
inside my tic tac i have got app.js and
index.html ready now here i am going to
create another file here called
app.css see you can basically put this
afterwards seriously in either folder
like in static folder but i have just
kept it outside
now from this point onwards i would like
to start with my basic functionalities
okay what those are let's start with the
first feature called morning
with my body
some basic settings i would like to do
like in background image background
color so i just start with
background color
background color i can just use it as a
white
okay
but i don't think so it's really needed
it so if you want you can have it
otherwise leave this background because
it's by default going to be white only
and now
next would be called height
height will be 800 pixels
next background position
background position i just say like
center
next background repeat in case if you do
not want to repeat the image
background repeat
and here i say no repeat
next background size
here we are saying cover
okay it resize the background image to
cover the entire container
okay so that's what the body part
now the next thing is we have to select
the
rest of the css classes so first select
div
dot relative
inside this dot relative is first say
call position
position we are saying absolute
next is stop
from the top i'm just making 760 pixels
next right
right is saying 120 pixels
next
after this we are saying height
container
height
dot
container oh sorry hide hyphen container
here in hide hyphen container we will
display
display
colon
none
well after that we have to use the
header point
header
inside the cellar we will say color
will be by default white but still we
just say color
and
white
next text line
we just say center
next margin
margin will be 50 pixels
next font family
font family i'm selecting called
permanent marker
permanent
permanent marker
okay next class we are talking about
call interplayer that's called dot
enter
hyphen
layers
and enter hyphen players with the same
color
will once again
we can use another clear but we can just
use white or any color you want
or you can just use
hash
okay
margin
margin we're giving it's called zero
auto width
we're looking forward for eighty percent
next texture line
center
position
relative
now
next we're going forward for input field
in this input field we just say border
border two pixels
solid
and black
next
outline
outline none
i do not want any outline to be there
next padding
i can take 4 pixels
8 pixels
four pixels eight pixels now margin
we are saying zero
zero ten pixels
okay and finally
for
pixels after smashing you say font size
18 pixels
okay so that is your input field
next we are talking about something
called input field focus
input
hyphen field
okay colon
focus
now here
border
two pixel
solid
right
or any other color which you want to use
it
next
how you want to submit button to be so
i'm saying
dot
submit hyphen btn
border
2 pixels
solid
and black
adding
8 pixels
and again 8 pixels
font size
18 pixels
now with
250 pixels
followed by border radius
5 pixels
next your margin from top
let's take 10 pixels
after that background color
let's take
white only
okay
so this is the property
now going forward you can associate
with your submit button active and
submit button focus so we are saying dot
submit
hyphen
btn
colon
active
and
two options we are taking
followed by condition outliner
outline
none
next border
we're talking about call 2 pixels
solid
and the color
red
okay
so that's the one
and uh after that we like to use over
dot
submit hyphen button
colon
over
what you want
change the background color
to what white
you can use white smoke
well
here we like to use
a
dot
board
here we'd like to use player
hyphen
so these are the classes we were using
in our javascript we remember
and here we say color
color we're using once again
right or you can use this white smoke
whichever you want
so
well later on
texture line
center margin
10 pixels
0
and 10 pixels
right
54 pixels
okay
so these are the properties initially we
have taken
okay so after this
turn let's go and start another classes
here i'm saying dot
name hyphen hyphen
style
and here we are saying color
red
and then font size
22 pixels
well
now coming back to the another
properties now we're talking about the
next important called border container
called board container dot
board container here we define width
which is 40 pixels we are taking
or sorry 40 percent we can rather take
after that background colors
that we can say coded blue
okay
next margin
we're taking is zero
and
auto
after that font size
size we are taking 0
next border
bottle we are taking 2 pixels
then solid
and then black
followed by
box shadow
you remember this worksheet is one of
the very very easy
three popular property here we're
defining three pixels
three pixels
three pixels
zero pixels
and
rgb
we can talk about called black
okay
so my
border color will be shading color will
be
black
after that we're offering this
board cell
dot
now in this board cell we're defining
width
now in this width we are using
calculation
ca lc and in this calculation we are
defining 100
okay divided by 3
this calculation
after this
the next property will be display
display will be inline block
next font size
we're taking 40 pixels
well texture line
center border
we are taking
two pixels
solid
and black
adding 20 pixels
vertical align
top
next font family
this formula can use permanent
permanent markers
okay
now
next option
a part of this
we have a call
your board cell circle
board
cell iphone
winner
i would say rather like
[Music]
let's make background color
red
okay
and
[Music]
later on just use
letter
now in this letter we just give the
color combination so color will be
white
next position
relative
top
50
next transform
translate by
to minus 50
after that font family
we are making it once again permanent
marker
let me copy
okay
now
here next option will be called winner
container
here we're giving
winner
with dot
dot
winner hyphen
container
okay so for this winner container
what are the values we want to use it
that's you want to basically do it so if
all this winner container what i would
rather suggest is you can use dot
reset
text line
center
margin
20 pixels are
that is for reset and now reset hidden
inside this reset today we will set
display name
display
none
okay after this the replay button
it's yeah
now it will talk about replay button dot
replay hyphen
vta
and here width
we make it
to
25
okay
and followed by padding
10 pixels we take it from here
and 20 pixels
border
this bottle we are taking is called two
pixels
followed by solid
okay
and black color
now later on
border radius
border radius we're taking five pixels
later on outline
i'm saying none
after this outline we say letter spacing
now this letter spacing would be again
zero
after that
text transform
this text track form value we are
talking about call
uppercase
next font size
font size
we're taking 16 pixels
then margin top
margin top would be 12 pixels
then word spacing
that you are taking three pixels
followed by background color
this you are taking white as usual
so this is for your replay button
okay now in a similar line we can also
have
call dot
replay hyphen
btn
colon hover
followed by dot
replay hyphen
active
now apply the common style outline
we are making it null
then color
we are making it is called white
then background color
will be black
okay
and
when it comes to the congratulations
so we'll be using this dot
okay
so this congratulations
class will be using font size
to what 24 pixels
and after this we are using this call
winner dot u
hyphen r
dot
winner
in this winner will be taking
font size
okay that's 18 pixels
after that
height we are taking 18 pixels again
then line height
line height we are taking 18 pixels
and then
margin two pixels
and then zero
okay that's it so
last but not least we would like to use
this
dot
replay
hyphen btn
this i am saying with 50 percent
50
percent
so this is what my css file is all set
i know it was pretty lengthy but it is
required for this particular application
okay everyone so we are all ready with
our css also now it's time to go back to
our index.html file
and take care about the final finishing
touch
so we have this index.html file with us
and now
the css class which we were using it in
our application that is known as call
this
permanent marker this class is not by
default available so we have to include
this
using this external api so here where we
have a call css with us
before that
we want
link
so within this link we want our
variable name called href
equal to now we have to give the proper
location by saying https
colon double forward slash fonts
dot google apis
okay dot com
slash css
question mark
family
equal to
permanent
plus
marker
okay so if you just copy this
into your browser
you will get to know
where exactly it is using
okay if i just copy and paste it
so i just need to say https before
yeah https
fonts
dot
google apis
dot com
slash
oh spelling wrong
css family equal to permanent marker
that is the main url
from where i can take this kind of font
so here
css so that's what i was cross verifying
it
well it's there we have included our css
also but in which class we need to use
that is an important now
js i also want to include it
so
here
in my head tag only
i would like to include
script
src equal to
app.js
so here my script is actually loaded now
after that
if i just go back and check
the
final outcome of my code
which is index.html5
well it pretty much look like in basic
nothing else has started when we talk
about call start game
okay so it needs to start because there
is no css class are attached so i need
to attach those classes within my code
so here onwards we have to start with
offering those css classes that at least
i can apply
those common behaviors to my application
okay like here we have a call
div
we haven't attached any class to this
after this body we have a part tip h1
class equal to header
tic tac toe then we have a call div we
have a call
body
under this we have a call another div
tag so
just imagine how many type of classes
are available one we have called tip
class equal to header
div class is closed again we have a call
one more div tag so like that multiple
css files are there where we have to
apply the new css class
to make it happen so now we have to just
go back and change our html and to apply
our main class
so this is what my final html which
looks like the same you can see we have
added all those type of css classes
which we had that is called inter player
player form player container label
placeholder and player container
and if you see all different type of
classes we have attached this to
okay because
here only my css class will get applied
and the javascript will apply those kind
of dynamic css based on certain
conditions so these css classes are
already there added inside your html
page
our app.css is ready
app.js is also ready now let's go back
and try to reveal how it looks like
awesome so it looks like pretty nice
tic tac toe is a game it is expecting
when it says start game it says you must
enter a name for each field validation
is working let me try to add
two names and say start game awesome so
now you can see it is saying a you are
up
now let me try to give the values
awesome now you can see
it's saying like hey you are a winner
great so guys congratulations on this
the first example of how the tic tac
door game is used so it is a classical
example of css
javascript and html together
this video on pygame we will teach you
how to develop games using the python
module called buy game so
let's get started
before we dive into the video let's get
a general overview of what you can
expect to learn from it
what's in it for you and what will you
know by the end of this video
the first thing that we will teach you
is what exactly is pygame you will
understand what exactly the pi game
module is and the various ways that you
can use it to develop games
next we will teach you how to install
pygame on your system
then we will take a look at the basic
components of pygame and finally we will
be using the pygame module and python
programming to develop a flappy bird
game which you can play in real life on
your own system
so
let's get started
so what exactly is pygame
pygame is a cross-platform python
software which was made specifically for
video game designing it includes
graphics visuals and sounds which can be
used to enhance the game which is being
designed by you
officially written by pete shiners to
replace pi sdl pi game is suitable to
create client-side applications that can
be potentially wrapped in a stand-alone
executable
to learn pi game it is required to have
a basic knowledge of python
now how do you go about installing pi
game on your system
to install pygame you can use the
standard pip install command in your
command prompt
then you can import it into your program
with the import command prompt in python
itself
before installing pygame python should
be installed in the system it is good to
have python
3.6.1 or above versions because it is
much friendlier to beginners and
additionally runs way faster
now what are the basic components of
pygame
the first and most important component
of pygame is the pygame.init module
this is used to initialize all imported
by game modules using this you can call
all pi game modules at once into your
program
before you can do much with pygame you
need to initialize it the most common
way to do this is to use pygame.init
this will initialize all the modules in
pygame with just one single command
not all pygame modules need to be
initialized but this will automatically
initialize the ones that are important
and the ones that have to be initialized
you can also easily initialize each pi
game module by hand
the next thing that you need to know
about is the display surface
the display surface is a black screen
which acts as a canvas for you to design
your games on
all the game components will appear on
this very screen
now pygame has a single display surface
that is either contained in a window or
runs full screen
once you create the display you can
cheat it as a regular surface
changes are not immediately visible on
screen
you must choose one of the two flipping
functions to update the actual display
the pygame display can actually be
initialized by one of several modes
by default the display is a basic
software driven frame buffer
you can require special modules like
hardware acceleration and opengl support
now pygame can only have a single
display active at any time
creating a new display will close the
previous display
once the display surface is created the
functions from this module affect the
single existing display
the surface becomes invalid if the
module is uninitialized
if a new display mode is set the
existing surface will automatically
switch to operate on the new display
the next concept is the game loop
the game loop is a piece of code that
does three things it will handle events
update game events and draw game state
to the screen
the game loop will basically run until a
condition is met or until the game ends
and finally you have pygame.quit
the pygame.quit function does the
opposite of the init function and
completely deactivates the pygame
library
it will automatically uninitialize all
pi game modules that have previously
been initialized
when the python interpreter shuts down
this method is called regardless so your
program does not always need it
except when it wants to terminate its
buy game resources and continue
it is safe to call this function more
than once as repeated calls have no
effect whatsoever
now please do note that calling
pygame.quit will not exit your program
consider letting your program end in the
same way a normal python program will
end
it will just help you break out of the
game loop
now let's see how we can create a flappy
bird game with the help of the python
pie game module so the first thing that
you're going to need is to call all of
your required modules
so over here we have imported the random
and the sys module we've imported the pi
game module and we've also imported all
the modules which are present in
bygame.locals
so let's run this so all the modules get
imported into a program
there we go now all of our pi game
modules have been imported
now the first thing that we're doing is
that we're setting global variables for
the game the window width and the window
height basically determine how big our
surface is going to be
after that we are going to
display our window
now you can call or create a window by
using pygame dot display dot set mode
and within set mode you set your window
parameters so you set your window width
and your window height
so here we will be creating a window of
width 600 and a fight 499.
the elevation will basically tell you
how far up from the bottom of your
screen the window is going to be
we're going to be creating an anti-tuple
of your game images and we're gonna be
having an fps of 32.
you can obviously change your fps speed
now all of these images that we're
importing have already been downloaded
onto your system
so all of these images are already here
and they're in the same folder that
we've stored our flappy bird game in
which is why to call them you simply
have to write the name of the image
and initialize it to a variable
so because we're creating flappy bird
we're going to have a pipe image
a background image
a bird and obviously a base which is
going to be a sea level and which you
have to prevent the bird from touching
so let's run this and create nothing but
a pie game window
so here as you can see a new window has
come up this so far is just a pie game
window nothing has been shown on it
because we haven't initialized any of
these parameters into a window as of yet
so far the only thing we've done is
create a basic window
which doesn't have any of the parameters
on it with the width of 600 and height
of 499
now here we are going to be coming into
our python game loop
so the first thing that we talk about in
our python game is that you have to have
some initialized variables right
and you have to create some important
components of the game
so the first thing
that you have is the flappy game which
is the game itself
the next thing that we have here is to
check if a game is over this is going to
happen under two conditions
one is
that the bird hits the pipe and the
second condition is that the bird falls
into the sea
and finally we will have a module to
create pipes of random height as and
when a bird
goes further into the screen
so basically the pipes will be created
as the user keeps going and not
beforehand
and finally here we have a main
game
loop which is going to be calling all of
these various functions that we've
created i'm just going to terminate
their run time the second
that the game gets over
and then following this we're going to
be exiting the flappy bird game
so your pie game dot quit as you can see
as we've already told you will close all
of the pie game modules that you've
already initialized in your program and
will uninitialize all of these modules
while sys.exit will exit the program
itself
now as we said the pygame dot quit
doesn't quit the program it only
uninitializes all the pi game modules
which is exactly why we're using
sys.exist to
close our window and exit our program
now the first thing that we're going to
be looking at is the flappy bird game
itself
the main things that are happening in
our flappy game is first of all we're
initializing variables and creating two
pipes by calling the create pipe
function
so at any given point we know that we
want a bird to fly in between two pipes
that is the main challenge here which is
exactly why we are initializing two
pipes here the first pipe and the second
pipe
and this is done by calling the create
pipe function
now after this we are going to be
creating two lists
one is of the lower pipes and the other
is of the upper pipes
now as we already talked about we are
going to have two pipes
consecutively yeah the first pipe is
going to be on top and the second pipe
is going to be at the bottom
so that's exactly what these two lists
contain they contain the height at which
the down pipes and the up pipes are
going to be or basically they contain
the coordinates at which these down
pipes and up pipes will be displayed at
now pipe well x is basically defining
the pipe velocity along your x-axis
and the bird velocity which is along the
y-axis is defined over here
so basically your bird is going to have
two different parameters one is that
it's gonna move up and down which is its
velocity along the y axis another is
it's going to move across which is its
velocity across the x-axis now at the
same time the pipes also have to keep
moving
and they have to exit this frame
so that's what this all of this is
defined by
the
bird acceleration is defined over here
this is the parameter that you're going
to be using to define your bird
acceleration along the y-axis that is
basically going to happen when you stop
clicking and the bird starts falling
downwards
now the velocity while flapping or the
x-axis velocity for the bird is defined
over here
now the bird is only going to be
flapping when you're going to be
pressing the key
so that's basically what you're going to
be checking here
if your event takes place which
basically means that
if you have key events and that's
exactly what pygame dot event dot get is
doing it's going to be getting all the
key functions that are taking place
on your keyboard simultaneously
so for event in dot event dot get will
basically help you get the key strokes
which are happening
if event type is equal to quit or event
type is equal to key down and event dot
key is equal to k dot escape you're
going to quit your game and you're going
to close down your program
so there are two ways that you can quit
your game you can either press quit
or
you can press key down and escape
now if your event type is equal to key
down and
your event dot key is equal to space or
k up so this is basically what you're
going to be using to make sure that your
bird is moving there are two main keys
which are going to be coming into play
over here you you can press the key down
as well as the space key or the key down
and the up key
so over here this is going to move your
bird
vertically and it's also going to make
sure that your bird flaps its wings
which is where the bird velocity which
are all these parameters will come into
play
so this will basically help your bird
move forward so basically what is
happening here is that we're going to be
getting
the keys that the user has pressed and
if they've pressed the quit key we're
going to quit the program and if they've
pressed key down and space or key down
and the up key we're going to make sure
that the bird starts moving in the
y-axis as well as it starts flapping its
wings and moving along in the x-axis
now this is the function
that checks for whether your bird has
crashed into pipes or not
this is basically also going to define
whether your game is over or not right
because once the bird touches a pipe the
game is basically finished so game over
here is is game over which is another
function that we are defining here
so basically what's happening over here
is that you're going to be checking if
the game is over by checking the
horizontal and vertical position of the
bird
and the positions of the up and down
pipes if the game is over then you will
return over here and you will basically
quit the whole game
now after this we need to keep track of
the score of the player
now how that can be done is
that you get your
position of your bird
and the position of your pipe and if the
bird has crossed the pipe then you
basically increase your score by one
if the current velocity of your bird
is less than the maximum velocity and
the bird has not flapped or you haven't
pressed your key in that case the bird
is basically going to be tumbling
downwards
now another thing that you have to
consider is
that the user has stopped pressing the
key right so the bird is not going to be
flapping its wings
if this is the case
then the bird has to free fall towards
the sea basically
so this is how we're going to be
checking it if the velocity of the bird
is less than the max velocity and the
bird has not flapped its wings
what we're going to be doing is we're
going to be increasing the present
velocity of the bird
in increments with an acceleration speed
that we've already defined over here
so if the bird starts flapping its wings
the velocity will steadily increase with
this acceleration
now if the bird has flapped its wings
after that we need to set the bird flap
function to false again
otherwise it will continue being true
which is not the case so we have to keep
switching it right the bird flap will
only be true when the user has pressed
the key after that it immediately has to
go back to
a false variable so that is basically
what we're doing here we're going to
change the bird flap to false
immediately after it has become true
now after this your pipes will keep
moving to the left
in this game the pipes are the ones that
are moving
horizontally the bird is not moving
horizontally the bird is only moving
vertically
so basically what we're going to be
doing is we're going to be increasing
the x coordinate of our pipe and the
pipe is not going to randomly start
increasing in height right so we're not
going to be touching the y coordinates
of the pipe
of the upper and the lower pipe we're
going to slowly increment the x
coordinate by the velocity factor that
we've already initialized previously
so the pipes will slowly keep moving by
this velocity factor towards the left
hand side of the screen
a new pipe will be added when the first
is about to cross the left most part of
the screen
so basically each pipe is covering about
five points on the x-axis and once it is
less than five but still greater than
zero we're going to create a new pipe
and we're gonna append it to our up
pipes
list
and we'll also be creating another pipe
and we're going to append it to a down
pipes list
now if the pipe is out of the screen we
basically have to remove it and this
we're going to do by popping out the
pipe from the up pipe list
so far we've looked at how we can
generate pipes for our
for our window
the velocity of the bird when it is
flapping its wings and what is going to
happen when it stops flapping its wings
handling uh the key pressing events that
the user is inputting
or checking whether a bird has crashed
or not updating our score
moving the pipes to the left and
creating new pipes once the previous
pipe has left the screen
now
the only thing that's left to do is
build a game image window because we've
dealt with almost all the game logic
that we need
so now we're basically going to start
building our pie game window
uh so first we're going to be putting
the image all throughout the screen
uh we're going to be rendering the up
pipe and down pipe at their respective
positions on the screen
and then we're going to be putting the
sea level and the bird on the screen
another thing that you need to do is
fetch the digits of the score and
display them on your screen so the
digits again all of the images have
already been included in our flappy bird
folder and all you have to do is display
them onto the screen
to do this all that we have to do is
loop through
our numbers list
and display the scoreboard images on the
side of our window
and this is the position at which
they'll be displayed
so here we're just displaying the images
on the screen
or the offset is again just a variable
that we've created here and that's a
variable at which we'll be displaying
the uh images
now every time the score changes you're
going to have to update the game window
so that is exactly what you're doing
here you're just updating your display
game window
and as we talked about every time your
display changes
you can't have two displays open at once
so the game will move on to this new
display window
and again we're just over here we're
just setting the frames per second
and that brings us to the end of
everything that we need to do this is
the basic game logic that we're going to
be needing so this whole
function just defines your game logic
let's finish running this
and your game logic has been initialized
into your program now
now the next thing that we have to do is
check if our bird is above sea level or
if it has hit any of the pipes so this
is what you use the is game over
function for
so the is game over function will have
four different parameters as input
so the is game over function has four
parameters you're going to be giving the
horizontal and the vertical height of
the bird
and the height
and position of the up pipes and the
downpipes
now there are basically
three conditions which lead to a
situation of the game being over
if the difference between a elevation
and a certain height is less than the
vertical it means that the bird has
crossed its boundaries and that is why
the game is over which is where you
return to
the another thing is that the bird hits
either the up pipes or one of the down
pipes
and that's what we're checking here
either the elevation of the bird has
decreased
and there's no way it can rise up again
and hence the game will be over
or
the bird has hit one of the pipes on top
of one of the bottom pipes
so that's basically what we're doing
here we're getting the height of the up
pipe and we're checking if the vertical
height of the bird is less than the pipe
height plus the pipe width
so basically it can hit the pipe
anywhere right so if this vertical
height is less than this parameter
as well as if the bird doesn't hit the
pipe horizontally so that's what we're
basically checking here
we're checking to see if the bird has
hit the pipe horizontally or vertically
then you will return true and the same
thing will happen for the
down pipes you will check if the bird
has hit the pipe horizontally or
vertically at any point
so let's run this game over function
the next thing that you have to do is
the create pipe function
now creating pipes is actually quite
easy all we have to do is fetch the
height of the pipe using the get height
function
and after that generate a random number
between 0
to any number such that the height of
the pipe should be adjustable to our
window height so there's only a certain
amount where you know you can have the
pipe visible and that has to be above
sea level
so we're going to be generating you know
like a random number between
0 and this number you know like 0 and
the width of your screen from height to
just above the c level
and then we're going to be
subtracting it by 1.2 into offset
because there's a huge chance that we
get like a pipe which covers the entire
screen so to prevent that we're going to
decrease the height of the pipes a
little
and then after that all we have to do is
push our pipes into a dictionary along
with their x-axis and y-axis coordinates
so this is basically what your pipe list
is going to look like it's going to be a
dictionary which consists of an upper
pipe and a lower pipe
and along with their coordinate values
so let's run this
now this is basically
the game loop that we're going to be
using um this is going to call our
various functions again and again
until the game basically gets over which
is defined over here
so this
function is going to run or this is your
basic game start it's going to keep
running
until a certain condition is met and
let's see what that condition is
so over here the different things that
we're doing initially is that we're
initializing
our program using pygame.init
we're basically calling all the modules
of the pygame library
then after that we're just setting the
frames per second
displaying the title of the
game on top of the game window
pygame.display.setcaption
um so far we only have a pie game window
right this is basically going to
initialize the background images and
everything onto this window
we're going to start loading all of our
different images into our game so we
have different images for the scores
the flappy bird image sea level
background and pipe image and we're
going to convert it into a form suitable
to display onto our
window
this is basically done using the
convert
image.load.convert
function
so over here you're basically going to
be loading your image
and converting it into a form which is
suitable to be displayed onto your
screen
after that we basically be doing a
couple of
basic startup things such as printing
welcome to flappy bird game and press
space or enter to start the game
and the second you see this you know
that this has started running properly
now this is where you have the main game
starting
so where you're basically going to be
setting the position of the bird and
horizontally we're going to be setting
it at one fifth of the window width
you can basically set the bird wherever
you want to
then after that we're going to be adding
the sea level and
over here we've initialized ground as
zero
while true for event in pygame dot event
dot get basically
while we keep getting a key stroke from
the user
this whole loop is going to keep running
and what exactly is happening in this
row loop over here basically we are
running the program until the user stops
or exits
the game
otherwise we have basically created an
infinite while loop over here
so if the event type is equal to quit
we're going to quit the game and exit
the program if the event type is key
down then we are going to be calling
flappy game so this is basically us
initializing the game start conditions
if the second
after the game starts the user clicks on
quit then we're going to quit the game
and exit the program
otherwise if the user has pressed the
key down the
space key or the key up then we're going
to be calling a flappy game function
if the user hasn't pressed any key and
nothing has happened then we're just
going to have a basic game display and
we're going to be displaying the
background image the flappy bird and the
sea level onto our screen
this is just to keep refreshing the
screen and this is basically to set the
frame rate of our screen so let's run
this now
if we look at our flappy bird game you
can see that we have
all of the parameters initialized we
have a background we have a c level and
we have our bird over here
we've typed flappy bird game on top and
i'm gonna press the enter key to start
so far as you can see our pipes have
appeared here
so we already know the function behind
this we keep getting our pipes and the
second that the bird crosses a pipe
the screen gets refreshed and our score
gets updated
so
if you notice here clearly
if i go slow enough and if you notice
the second i did this
the display window actually got
refreshed
and the second the pipe goes out of
screen you as you can see it gets erased
and a new pipe enters so the second this
one pipe goes out a new pipe gets
created
now
as we've talked about there are three
basic conditions one is you hit the
bottom pipe and the game ends
another is you hit the
top pipe anywhere in the game ends and
the next one is your bird falls below a
certain level and the game ends so these
conditions are working so far our
scoreboard also keeps getting
initialized
another condition that you might want to
check for
oh yeah and as you can see another thing
that you notice is the velocity right so
the bird is technically not moving the
bird's position relative to where it
started from remains exactly the same as
you can see here the only thing that is
moving is its position on the y-axis
apart from this the pipes are moving
and do you remember the acceleration
parameter that we have this is where you
can see it come into the into play
so i stopped and this
the way the bird free falls all of this
is because of the acceleration parameter
that we set
so this is basically how you can use pi
game to
you know create a game
now let us
quit the game
i press the escape key and the entire
game has quit
so over here
system exit took place as you can see
so this is all the logic that we've
used behind creating a flappy bird game
and as you can see we've used the pi
game module to create it
this particular video is based on the
interview questions asking some of the
most popular mnc companies such as
amazon google and ibm yes the question
about gaming is an integral part of
interview questions from the top mnc
companies to test the object oriented
programming skills of a developer
now there are not a lot of games that we
will be discussing today there are three
most frequently asked gaming questions
that are the snake game parcel game and
the ping pong game
so we have open source this particular
code from google and github and we have
also placed the links in the description
box below and along with that and also i
have personally made a document of all
the codes used in this particular video
for you so that you can have access to
it and write the code in your own local
system
so the first game that we will be
discussing today is the snake game so
this particular snake game is most
frequently asked in the top mnc company
such as amazon and flipkart
now let's get into the eclipse window
and try to execute the code
so now we are in the eclipse window and
on my screen you can see a code based on
the simple snake so basically this
particular snake game on my screen has
the snake trees and its directions based
on the keystroke you give that is right
left up down etc and the start game
option
and stop the game option
like if you want to pause it in the
middle and after that the energy used
treats eaten moving snake grow snake etc
etc so now we'll try to start this game
and see how it functions
yeah there you go
you can see that the program got started
and the output is on my screen so you
just need to click to start
so there you go the snake is around here
it's actually fun to play
so that's how you program it
and don't worry about the code the open
source github link for this particular
code is placed in the description box
below and this particular quote is also
written as a text document and that text
document is also attached in the
description box below
now we will move ahead with our next
game
so the next game is
the puzzle game so this particular game
is asked and some of the popular mnc
companies like google now let's look
into the code which is really simple and
try to execute this on the eclipse
so now we are back on the eclipse
so you can see on my screen we have the
code for the alphabet puzzle game that
we are going to execute so basically
this particular alphabet is going to
have
three rows and three columns so in total
we'll be having nine cells out of which
eight cells will be occupied so one
particular cell which is a nine cell
will be empty for the motions
now we have a b c d e f g and h
and one empty space which is a block b8
now let's try to execute this code and
see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and we have the
puzzle game on my screen right now
so you can see it's almost already
arranged luck by chance maybe so just
let's click the on the edge so now you
can see that we have won the particular
game and it is in the ordered sequence
that is a b c d e f g
and h since we have done the arrangement
proper the game shows we have one
congratulations you won now let's just
press ok and let's continue with our
next game
so the third game that we will be
discussing today will be about the ping
pong game
so this particular ping-pong game is
asked in some of the famous mnc
companies like ibm
now let's try to execute this particular
code on the eclipse window and see the
output
so now we are back on the eclipse window
so this particular game will have three
classes that has the ball class which is
the movement of the ball next we have
the paddle which is all about the boat
and the paddles that we play with
and next the punk this particular class
is all about how the code runs or how
the game runs
now let's try to execute this particular
program and see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and we have the
pawn game over here
yeah so that's how you play it
please don't worry about the codes we
have the open source github links for
all the games we have used in the
description box below along with that we
have also placed a text document of all
the codes used in this particular video
you can have access to it and try to
execute that code in your local system
now with that we have come to an end of
this session on game development
tutorial hope the session was
interesting and informative if you have
any queries regarding any of the topics
covered in this session or if you
require the resources that we used in
this session like code ppt etc then do
let us know in the comment section below
and our team of experts will be more
than happy to resolve all your queries
at the earliest until next time thank
you stay safe and keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you